ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BILL. GORGEOUS BRADFORD COPY AT
ALL CHIANG. DAWALY DOT THE
RUSSELL GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALES GROW. BURKE HILL. SO
TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL OWNING LOCKED
MORRELL NIELSEN PAN TWENTYNINE
ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER STERN.
STONE NUMBER Y. CASKEY WIENER
WILK. A QUORUM IS PRESENT. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS WELCOME BACK
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND JOHN P. MCCURRY. SJ
PRESIDENT OF THE JESUIT HIGH
SCHOOL. AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING AND WE WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG BY SENATOR JERRY
HILL. GOD OF LIFE AND LIGHT AND
LOVE. OPEN OUR HEARTS TO YOU
THIS DAY. MAY WE LIVE IN HOPE
AND JOY. LET US SERVE WITH
OPTIMISM AND COURAGE MAY WE
LEAD WITH FAITH AND INTEGRITY.
YOU ARE THE GOD OF ALL PEOPLE
SO HELP US BE SERVANTS IN THE
SPIRIT OF YOUR HOLY NAME.
STRIVING ALWAYS TO KEEP THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE AND REPRESENT
AS OUR PRIMARY FOCUS. GOD OF
JUSTICE AND PEACE FILL US WITH
YOUR LOVE SO THAT ALL THAT WE
DO IS DONE WITH RESPECT FOR THE
OTHER. AND FOR THE EARTH ARE
COMMON HOME. BLESS THIS BODY OF
LEADERS AND LEGISLATORS WITH
YOUR SPIRIT OF WISDOM AND RIGHT
JUDGMENT KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING. WE PRAISE YOU
GOD FOR YOUR GOODNESS AND
FAITHFULNESS TO US NOW AND
ALWAYS A MAN. YOU JOIN ME AS WE
SALUTE OUR FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. SIX OF
HER. THIS IS HANDS. MOVING ON
THE IN ON THE AGENDA.
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE POINT TEN BE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE TRANSFERRED TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB EIGHT NINETY SIX. THERE
ARE FOUR AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK
AND THEY WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SEVENTY FIVE A.
B. FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
IT'S AN INACTIVE FILE. SO
ORDERED. SENATE MCGUIRE THANK
YOU SO MUCH BETTER PRESENT GOOD
AFTERNOON AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM TO SIXTY SIX
AB TWO SEVEN FIVE TWO SEVEN
FOUR TO THE INACTIVE FILE ON
BEHALF OF THE SILLY WOMAN
BURKE. SO NOTED THANK YOU.
SENIOR FOR THEIR ITEMS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
THE SECOND READING FILE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX SIXTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
BILL. EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR NINE
SEVENTY ONE SO MAJORA'S LUCIEN
TEN ASSEMBLY BILL. 991-378-6957
SEVENTY FOUR SECOND READING IS
DEEMED READ AND ALL AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. TAKE UP THE FIRST
ITEM. WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
THAT PARTICULAR ITEM. AND MOVE
ON TO SENATE THIRD READING. THE.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA START WITH
THE UNFINISHED BUSINESS AND
WE'LL START WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. IF I COULD
I'M GOING TO ENCOURAGE EVERYONE
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE ON THE
FLOOR WE'RE GOING TO START
TAKING SOME VOTE AND IT'S GOING
TO BE IMPORTANT SO ITEM NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. SENATOR Y.
KOWSKI. CLERK GREETS OKLA
COOKERY. SENATE BILL THREE OH
THREE BY SENATOR Y. CASKEY AN
ACTUAL INTO GUARDIANS AND
CONSERVATORS. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MEN PRESENT SB THAT THREE
OH THREE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
THE COURT BE NOTIFIED. ABOUT A
PROPOSED SALE OF CONSERVANCY'S
RESIDENCE BEFORE SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES ARE DEVOTED TO THE
ACTION AND FURTHER
CLARIFICATION THE EXISTING LAW
PROTECTING CONSERVANCY'S A
GOVERNMENT BENEFITS AYE URCHIN
I VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BELL. HI PORGES HI BRADFORD. W.
AT ALL HI I CHIANG. DALY HI
DODD HI THERE ALSO. BY GALGIANI
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH
HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TADO HI JACKSON I JONES. I
LEYVA. MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL HI
MONNING. MORE LOCK. MORRELL HI
NIELSEN. BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS BY RUBIO I SKINNER BY
STERN. I STONE HI NUMBER IOWA
CASKEY. HI WINNER HI WILK HI
THESE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS BATES HI BRADFORD HI
CHIANG. GALGIANI AYE LEYVA HI
MONNING HI MORE LOCK HI. WHAT
CUSTOMERS A CALL. MEMBERS W'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT AND WE'LL START
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE SIXTY
SEVEN SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
BOTTOM ONE SIXTY SEVEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF CAN HAUL TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD OF GOVRNORS BALL I KNEW
THAT. MISTER HALL IS A PARTNER
A GORDON CREED KELLY HOLE AND
SUGAR MEN AND ALSO ADJUNCT
FACULTY AT THE UNIVERSITY SAN
FRANCISCO SCHOOL A LOT HE WAS
PROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JULY TENTH A UNANIMOUS VOTE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I HOPE SENATOR
WIENER AND APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
THANK YOU MADAM I PRESENT I'D
IS GOING TO SPEAK ROCK I RISE
IN FAVOR OF A CONFIRMING KEVIN
HALL TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS I'VE KNOWN
HIM FOR A LONG TIME HE IS A
FANTASTIC LEADER IN OUR
COMMUNITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL I PURCHASED AYE BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL I CAN I CHIANG
I DALY. DODD. I THE RAZZLE AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE
I JACKSON BY JONES. LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL AYE MONNING
I'M MORE LUCK. RAIL NO NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I STERN
AYE STONE. NO NUMBER I WOULD
COUNTY. BY WINNER HI WILK HI HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA HI. ATKINS DALY. NO
JONES NO MORE LOCK. I THIRTY
FOUR KNOWS FOR THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFORM. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM ONE SEVENTY
TWO SENATOR WELLS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY TWO SO
CONFIRMATION OF GEHRY STRONG
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE WATER
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD SAN DIEGO
REGION MISTER SHARON IS RETIRED
ENGINEERING CONSULTANT AND U.
S. NAVY VETERAN THAT SERVED ON
THE BOARD SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND TEN HE IS ALSO THE BOARD'S
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE SAN DIEGO
RIVER CONSERVANCY. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON AUGUST TWENTY FIRST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS CONFIRMATION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES. BELL
FIVE LARGEST. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG I DALY DODD.
HI THERE I WAS A AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ. HI
GROWTH. WE HAVE A CALL AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO SO
I OR TITLES OF SOME TOLD AYE
JACKSON. I JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK WHO SHE'S MORALE. NIELSEN
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NUMBER OUR COUNTY I
WINNER BY WILK HI HI THIS CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS THE
RIVER BATES HE WITH THEM I LIKE
AND POOR JUST HI GOOD TO HAVE A
FRIEND DALLY IF YOU NEED IT
YEAH MORE LOCK DELI. DELI I.
MORE LOCK MORRELL. STONE. ICE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MOVING ON TO ITEM ONE SEVENTY
THREE SENATOR WELCOME THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY THREE SO
CONFIRMATION THE FOLLOWING
WATER CONTROL WATER QUALITY
CONTROL BOARD APPOINTMENTS JEAN
GREY FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO THE
CENTRAL COAST REGIONAL BOARD
MARK BRADFORD TO ENTITIES CAN
DERA FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BOARD AND MEGAN
BLAIR AND CELESTE CAN'T TO THE
SAN DIEGO BOARD. THESE
APPOINTMENTS WERE APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON THE
TWENTY FIRST OF AUGUST ON
UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON ANY OF THESE KINDS
CONFIRMATIONS. SEEING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES HI BILL BY
BURGESS BY BRADFORD. I KELLY AT
ALL I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD.
THE RUSSELL I GALGIANI HI
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE TADO I JACKSON I JONES. HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING AYE MOORLACH I'M
REAL AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROSS I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. STERN BY STONE. HI
NUMBER FIVE A CASSIE AYE WIENER
AYE WILK HI. PLEASE CALL THE UP
TO MEMBERS. ATKINS DOT HI GROVE.
HI SKINNER. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED MEMBERS THAT
CONCLUDES THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS WILL GO WILL MOVE
BACK TO THE SENATE. THIRD
READING. A. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
OKAY. OKAY. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM ONE SEVENTY
NINE WHICH IS UNDER UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. CENTRE BELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. YES.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FIVE A
SENATOR BILL RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. CENTRE BELL WE
HAD SOME AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY ON THIS BILL ON THIS
RESOLUTION. AND THE RESOLUTION
URGES CONGRESS TO AND PRESENT
TO WORK ON INFRASTRUCTURE
LEGISLATION AND FUNDING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. CENTER
GROVE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I WOULD ASK EVERYBODY TO VOTE
NO THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
ACTUALLY IN ASK CONGRESS TO
INCREASE THE FEDERAL GAS TAX WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST GAS TAX IN THE
NATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
HAVE FAMILIES THAT I REPRESENT
THAT ARE MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT
PUTTING GAS IN THEIR CAR FOOD
ON THEIR TABLE THERE ARE SOME
OF US THAT PAY FOR THE GAS TAX
AND WE DON'T EVEN GET BOTHERED
BY IT BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHER PEOPLE MAKING VERY
DIFFICULT IS DECISIONS IN
SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION.
WOULD ENCOURAGE CONGRESS TO
INCREASE THE FEDERAL GAS TAX
ADDED TO THE INCREASE IN STATE
GAS TAXES WHICH IS A
DETRIMENTAL SAYS SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE SO I WOULD
ASK FOR A NO VOTE. THERE
ANYBODY ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SENATE ABOUT. THANK
YOU THE RESOLUTION DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY ANYWAY US FOR A
GAS TAX INCREASE FOR LEVEL AYE
AYE ORIGINAL VOTE ON MEASURE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
NOBEL I PURCHASED. NO BRADFORD.
I COMING AT ALL I CHIANG. NO
DALY NO DODD HI THE RUSSELL BY
GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ.
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO I TITLE. JACKSON
JONES. NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. BY MORNING I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. BY ROTH BY
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NO I'M BURKE CASKEY I
WINNER HI WILK NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS
GONZALEZ. HI TADO. JACKSON HI.
HER EYES TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS
ELEVEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED. ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY CENTER DORADO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FOR NINETY FIVE MESSENGER
DORADO AND ACTUALLY CHILD
CUSTODY SENATOR DURAZO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB FOUR
NINE FIBER PROHIBIT A COURT
FROM CONSIDERING SEX GENDER
IDENTITY OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OF A PARENT GUARDIAN A RELATIVE
DURING A COURT'S DETERMINATION
OF A CHILD'S BEST INTEREST WHEN
AWARDING CHILD CUSTODY OR
VISITATION RIGHTS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS SIMPLY ADDRESSED
CHAPTER IN CONCERNS WITH THE
FAMILY LAW OMNIBUS BILL AB
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN
AND ADD CO AUTHORS. THIS
MEASURE SUPPORTED BY QUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN CONCURRENCE WITH
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. BELL
BY BURGESS BRADFORD OUR-
BRADFORD I CARRIER I CHIANG I
DALY. DODD AYE THERE ALSO HI BY
GOD. HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL BY WITH SOME.
I TITLE. I JACKSON AYE JONES.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
HI MONNING HI MORE LOCK MORALE.
NIELSEN HI. PAN BY PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE. NUMBER.
IRAQ OWSKI I WINNER HI WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS. BATES BURGESS. DALY.
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
JONES MORE LOCK MORRELL. STONE.
ICE THIRTY ONE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO ONE
EIGHTY TWO SENATOR BELL. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR BILL AN ACTOR IN A
PUBLIC CONTRACTS. CENTRE BELL
MAN PRESENT MEMBERS THIS BILL
SB ONE TWENTY EIGHT WILL EXTEND
THE EXISTING SUNSET OF THE BEST
VALUE CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTING
PROGRAM TO FIVE ADDITIONAL
YEARS AND WAY OUT THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND MODERATE
COUNTY TO THE PILOT THE CURRENT
LAW SUNSETS AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR WELL MANY COUNTIES ARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF IMPLEMENTING
THEIR BEST VALUE SELECTION
PROCESS UNLIKE THE LOW COST
CONTRACT MATH LOW BID CONTRACT
METHOD THE BEST VALUE CUT
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTING
PROGRAM. CREATES A LARGER
CONTRACTOR BIDDING PULL REDUCES
BAD ACTORS INCREASES THE AMOUNT
OF SKILL CRAFT WORKERS ON
COUNTY CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
THIS WILL LEAD TO MORE PROJECTS
BEING FINISHED ON TIME AND ON
BUDGET ARE CHEN AYE VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES HI BILL I BRIDGES AYE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD. I
DORADO. I GALGIANI. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE
I JACKSON I JONES. I LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL. BY MORNING
I'M MORE LUCK I AM A REAL. AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG.
OUR COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS GALGIANI. GLAZER I ROVE
WILK WELCOME BY. THERE WILL BE
MISTER ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY THREE
SENATOR PORTANTINO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FIVE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MISTER THANK YOU ARE MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SB FIVE SIX EIGHT
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY. ALLOW GLENDALE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
APPROPRIATELY COMMEMORATE THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE BY TKING AN
CLOSING TAKING OFTEN CLOSING ON
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH I SEVERAL
YEARS AGO THE GLENDALE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. GIVEN ITS
LARGE ARMENIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND STUDENT
POPULATION APPROPRIATELY CLOSED
ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
EDUCATION CODE ALLOWS THEM TO
DO THAT. UNFORTUNATELY WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IT GLENDALE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WAS FACED
WITH THE SITUATION OF IF THEY
CLOSE IN APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
THEY WOULD LOSE UP TO A HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TAKING THAT
DAY OFF. I AB FIVE SIX EIGHT
ALLOWS GLENDALE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TO ALIGN ITS CALENDAR
WITH ITS LOCAL K. TWELVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IMAGINE A FAMILY WHO
HAS A CHILD WHO WANTS TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THE
COMMEMORATION IN AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL BUT THEIR OLDER SIBLING
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE HAS TO GO
TO CLASS IT'S JUST NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD LET
HAPPEN AND PLEASE THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. OFFICE
HELPED DRAFT THESE AMENDMENTS
AND WOULD APPRECIATE AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. THE THING MAN MISTER
SECRETARY RURAL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES HI
BILL BY BURGESS HI BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHIANG AYE DALY
AYE DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE AYE AYE HILL AYE
HUESO AYE TADO I JACKSON HI
JONES. LEYVA I AM A CHOIR. HI
MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK MORALE. HI NILSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH HI
RUBIO. SKINNER BY STERN. STONE.
NUMBER FIVE A COUNTY I WIENER
AYE WILK HI. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS GROW.
JONES. GROW BY JONES I MORE
LOCK HI RUBIO BY STERN I. STONE.
ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR
SENATOR SKINNER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY THREE OF US
SENATOR SKINNER AND NOT GOING
TO INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS. FLOOR IS YOUR
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCY CREATES AN
OAKLAND SPECIFIC INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICT AND IT IS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR CURRENT
FINANCING DISTRICT LAWS. IT
SUPPORTS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS AND FIRE STATIONS AND
WOULD ALSO ASSIST IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND A HOPEFUL
STADIUM WHICH IS STILL FAR IN
THE FUTURE BUT HOPEFULLY WILL
ASSIST THERE AND WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THING
NINE PLEASE READ. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MISTER SECRETARY ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES.
BELL I PURCHASED NO BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL I CHIANG. DALY
DOT. I THE RUSSELL AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TITLE HI JACKSON BY
JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK. MERRELL NO NIELSEN. HI
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. HI I RUBIO.
SKINNER AYE STERN. STONE.
NUMBER OUR CASKEY BY WIENER AYE
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS BATES. CHIANG
DALY GROVE. JONES. MORE LOCK BY
RUBIO AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE.
WILK. ICE THIRTY ONE NOTE KNOWS
TO THE AMENDMENT SECOND CURTAIN
ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE. SENATOR
STONE PASS ON FILE. SENATORS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
SENATE THIRD READING. AND THE
FIRST ITEM IS ONE EIGHTY NINE.
SENATOR WEST SO. PASS ON FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY. SENATOR DIED.
MISTER MISTER SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTY
FOUR BY SENATOR DODD RELATIVE
TO NATIONAL CYBER SECURITY
AWARENESS MONTH SENATOR DODD
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY
AND PRESENTE SR FIFTY FOUR
PERTAINING TO NATIONAL CYBER
SECURITY AWARENESS MONTH
CYBERSECURITY AWARENESS MONTH
SPONSORED BY THE NATIONAL CYBER
SECURITY DIVISION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
AND THE NATIONAL CYBER SECURITY
ALLIANCE IS OBSERVED EACH
OCTOBER NATIONWIDE OVER THE
LAST THREE DECADES INTERNET IS
HAD A REVOLUTIONARY IMPACT ON
ALL PARTS OF. SOCIETY BOB FROM
A PERSONAL RELATIONSHIPS IN
SOCIAL INTERACTIONS TO SCHOOLS
HOSPITALS ECONOMIES AND
GOVERNMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
CRITICAL TO PUBLIC SAFETY AND
NATIONAL SECURITY WE RELY ON
THIS SITE AN ACTIVITY IN DEPEND
ON THESE DEPENDENT
COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGIES THAT
THEY WORK SEAMLESSLY RELYING SO
HEAVILY ON THIS CAN ACTIVITY
HAS INTRODUCED NEW RISK
ESPECIALLY TO OUR FINANCES OUR
IDENTITY IN PRIVACY A RECENT
STUDY REPORTED THAT FROM TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TODAY THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE HAS RECEIVED REPORTS OF
DATA BREACHES AFFECTING OVER
FIFTY MILLION RECORDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. I ASK YOU TO JOIN
ME IN RECOGNIZING OCTOBER HAS
NATIONAL CYBER SECURITY
AWARENESS ABOUT IT
PARTICIPATING THIS MONTH ARE
DESIGNED TO EMPHASIZE PERSONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF TAKING PROACTIVE
STEPS IT FOCUS ON KEY AREAS
INCLUDING CITIZEN PRIVACY
CONSUMER DEVICES IN ECONOMIC
SECURITY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON SR. FIFTY FOUR.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR. WE HAVEN'T OKAY
NEVER MIND THIS ISN'T A
CANDIDATE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALAN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES HI BILL BY
BURGESS I BRADFORD. HI. ZERO HI
JANE I DALY AYE DODD. HI THERE
ALSO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE TITLE BY
JACKSON HI JONES. BY LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI MONNING
BY MORE LUCK. HIGH MORALE BY
NELSON. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO BY
ROTH BY RUBIO. SKINNER. I STERN
HI STONE. I AM BURKE I WOULD
COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS RUBIO. HI. ICE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE NINETY TWO SENATOR
SKINNER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTY
NINE BY SENATOR SKINNER
RELATIVE TO CHILDREN'S
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH MONTH
TWENTY NINETEEN. CENTER SKINNER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. WE
HAVE ALREADY BOTH NATIONALLY
AND IN THE STATE R. D. CLEARED
A DAY IN OCTOBER AS CHILDREN'S
HEALTH DAY BUT THAT'S A BROAD
BASED ON TRYING TO PROMOTE
BETTER HEALTH FOR CHILDREN WHAT
THIS RESOLUTION DOES IS THE
CLEAR. OCTOBER ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH MONTH FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THE MOTIVATION
BEHIND IT IS THAT CHILDREN'S
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH MADE IS
THAT THERE ARE MANY OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL TOXINS THAT HAVE
FAR MORE SEVERE EFFECTS ON
CHILDREN'S BODIES INFANTS
BODIES THEN ON ADULTS SO THAT
THEY ARE FAR MORE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO WHATEVER CONSEQUENCES OF
THOSE SO I BRING THIS TO OUR
ATTENTION AND I ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT S. R. FIFTY NINE SO
THAT WE CAN DO THAT MUCH MORE
TO PROTECT CHILDREN'S. HEALTH
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. FIVE THREATS TO
A CHILD'S SELF THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR DRAWS A-
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION I DO SO KNOWING HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO TRANSLATE
ITS WORDS INTO LAW. I HAVEN'T
BEEN SUCCESSFUL YET IN GETTING
A BAN ON THE PESTICIDE
CHLORPYRIFOS TO THE FLOOR OF
EITHER HOUSE. DESPITE THE
OVERWHELMING. FOSS BEING BANNED
FOR USE IN YOUR HOMES FOR
DECADES. YEAH WHEN IT COMES TO
FARMWORKERS CHILDREN WE KEEP
FINDING WAYS TO CONTINUE ITS
USE. I HOPE WE CAN BAND THIS
NEUROTOXIN BEFORE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE CHILDREN'S
ENVIRONMENTAL MONTH NEXT YEAR.
SPECK FULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF SR FIFTY NINE THANK.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NINE CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THE ONLY
ADDITION I WOULD ADD IS THAT
CLEARLY IT'S NOT CLEARLY
PESTICIDES AND OTHER TOXINS.
THE RESEARCH SHOWS HAS FOR MORE
IMPACT BOND THE DEVELOPING
CHILD AND- FIVE VARIOUS
CONSEQUENCES TO THEIR HEALTH
BUT BEYOND THAT THINGS SUCH AS
AIR POLLUTION AS WE KNOW AS THE
RISE IN CHILDHOOD ASTHMA DUE TO
PARTICULATE POLLUTION ANOTHER'S
SO MORE RESEARCH IS NEEDED FOR
US TO UNDERSTAND HOW ALL THE
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINANTS IMPACT CHILDREN IN
THEIR DEVELOPMENT AND THAT IS
THE PURPOSE OF HAVING A
RESOLUTION SUCH AS THIS AND
DECLARING A MONTH. LIKE THIS
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE. CALL
THE ROLL WE DON'T HAVE
UNANIMOUS ALLEN. BY ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES HI BILL HI
BRIDGES I BRADFORD HI KELLY
HERO I TING AYE DALY AYE DODD.
HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG HILL HI. HUESO I OUR
TITLE HI JACKSON HI JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MORNING BY MORE LUCK I'M A
REAL. HI NELSON HI PAN AYE
PORTANTINO BY ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
I AMBERG I WOULD COUNTY I
WINNER BY WILK HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS.
GROWTH HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
NINETY FOUR SENATOR HILL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SIXTY BY SENATOR
HILL RELATIVE TO SEPSIS
AWARENESS MONTH. SENATOR HILL
OF FOUR YEARS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT S. R.
SIXTY WHICH DESIGNATES THE
MONTH OF SEPTEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN AS SEPSIS AWARENESS
MONTH SEPSIS IS THE RESULT FROM
AN OVERWHELMING IMMUNE RESPONSE
TO INFECTION WERE IMMUNE
CHEMICALS ARE RELEASED INTO THE
BLOOD STREAM TO COMBAT THE
INFECTION WHICH TRIGGERED
WIDESPREAD INFLAMMATION. SEPT
IS AN EGG EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
KILLER WHICH DOES NOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST AGE OR
ETHNICITY AND CAN RESULT FROM
COMMON INFECTIONS SUCH AS
PNEUMONIA AND INFLUENZA SEPSIS
KILLS MORE AMERICANS THAN
PROSTATE CANCER BREAST CANCER
AN OPIOID OVERDOSE IS COMBINED.
AND IT HAS THE HIGHEST
MORTALITY RATE AMONG YOUNG
CHILDREN AND THE ELDERLY EACH
YEAR AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE DIE IN
THE UNITED STATES DUE TO SEPSIS
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONE.
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA DIED IN THE HOSPITAL
DUE TO SEPSIS THE NUMBER
DOESN'T ENCOMPASS THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF SEPSIS DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
INCLUDE THOSE WHO DIE OUTSIDE
OF THE HOSPITAL. FORTUNATELY
TREATMENTS EXIST RECEPTORS IN
OFTEN LIVES CAN BE SAVED WITH
TIMELY REACTION AND TREATMENTS
OF THE TREATMENT OF SEPSIS
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS ARE ABLE
TO GREATLY INCREASE THE
SURVIVAL RATE AND MITIGATE THE
LONG LASTING EFFECTS RAISING
AWARENESS OF SYMPTOMS IS KEY.
TO KNOWING WHEN TO SEEK
TREATMENT AND WILL REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF DEATH FROM SEPSIS IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS OUR SIXTY
ENCOURAGE ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
MAKE THEMSELVES AWARE OF THIS
DEADLY CONDITION. RECREATION
I'VE COLLEAGUES. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BILL. I BRIDGES I
BRADFORD I CAL YELLOW I CHIANG
I DALY AYE DODD. I THE RAZA AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE HER
TITLE. BY JACKSON I JONES HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
BY MORNING I'M MORE LUCK I'M
RAIL BY NELSON. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
I AMBERG IOWA CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK LOOK AT. THE ICE FORTY
NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE NINETY FIVE SENATOR
WEST SO. WE'RE GONNA PASS THAT
ONE. AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
SENATE THIRD READING. MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. WE'RE
GONNA START WITH ITEM NUMBER
TWO THIRTY TWO. SENATOR.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ AS SOME
OF THE ONE THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
THAT GOING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
CENTER MCGUIRE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AT A DIFFERENT DESK YOU
WERE TRYING TO TRICK ME BUT I
BUT LIKELY HAD SOME HELP. IN MY
MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT. ABLE TO
BE HERE RISE RISEN AB THIRTEEN.
SIX ONE THIRTY SIX AND WE HAVE
AS A MEMBER QUIRK SILVA WHICH
WAS INTRODUCED IN RESPONSE TO
THE COLLEGE ADMISSIONS SKETCHES
WHICH WERE ALL VERY FAMILIAR
WITH. IN MARCH FOR THAN FIFTY
PEOPLE WERE INDICTED BY FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS FOR CHARGES
INCLUDING BRIBING COLLEGE
OFFICIALS. TO SECURE COLLEGE
ADMISSION FOR THEIR CHILDREN AB
ONE THIRTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE
THOSE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS WHO
ARENAMED IN THE FEDERAL
INDICTMENT. AND FOUND GUILTY
TWO MEN THEIR PERSONAL IN OUR
BUSINESS EIGHT TAX RETURNS AND
DISCLOSURES. THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN HAS NO OPPOSITION
BUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE. THE MEASURE PASSES IF
THERE IS NO OBJECTION TO IT
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTION THE MEASURE
PASSES I IS FORTY KNOWS ZERO.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
THIRTY THREE. SENATOR PAN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA ENACT
WILLING TO PUBLIC HEALTH CENTER
PAN FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS SOME
PLEASE PRESENT EIGHTY TWO SIXTY
TWO BY SUMMER GLORIA. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SAN DIEGO EXPERIENCE
ONE THE DEADLIEST OUTBREAKS OF
HEPATITIS A- SCENE BECAME
AVAILABLE FOR THE FORWARD THIS
DISEASE IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
THE OTHERWISE. ENTIRELY
PREVENTABLE DISEASE BEGAN TO
SPREAD AND IT DID SO AND THE
BEAT UNBELIEVABLE RATE OF
REACHING UP TO ORANGE LOS
ANGELES EVEN AS FAR SANTA CRUZ
COUNTIES. STATE INVENTION
BECAME SO DESPERATELY NEEDED AS
A RESULT OF THE HEPATITIS A
OUTBREAK ORIGINE IN SAN DIEGO
THE FORMER GOVERNOR BROWN
ISSUED AN EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION ON OCTOBER
THIRTEENTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AS
OF APRIL ELEVENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REPORTED SEVEN HUNDRED FOUR
CASES FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND TWENTY ONE
DEATHS RELATED TO THIS
HEPATITIS A OUTBREAK STATEWIDE.
FOLLOWING CONTAINER THE
OUTBREAK THE STATE AUDITOR
REVIEW THE MANAGEMENT OF THIS
OUTBREAK SHE PROVIDED A NUMBER
OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO ALL
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES INVOLVED
THIS BILL IS A DIRECT PRODUCT
OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS. AB
TWO SIXTY TWO MAKES CLEAR TO
RESPONSIBILITIES OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS PROTECT THE PUBLIC
AGAINST FUTURE COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE OUTBREAKS SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL CLARIFIES A LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER TO FORTY TWO
ISSUE HEALTH ORDERS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN RESPONSE TO
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE OUTBREAK.
AND REQUIRES A LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER TO MAKE RELEVANT
INFORMATION INCLUDING THE
LOCATIONS OF CONCENTRATION THE
CASES RELATED TO THE
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE OUTBREAK
AVAILABLE TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITHIN THE COUNTY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BY BELL FIVE LARGEST
AYE BRADFORD AYE COMING AT ALL
I CHIANG I DALY. I DODD HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ. I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
OUR TITLE I JACKSON I JONES BY
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING. I'M MORE LOCK.
MORALE NIELSEN. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROB I RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE I
AM BURKE OUR COUNTY BY WINNER.
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE APPS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GROW BY. MORE LOCK. MORRELL. BY
NIELSEN HI WIENER. FIVE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
BEYOND TO ITEM TWO THIRTY FOUR
SENATOR HILL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SIXTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO NECRO IN THE UNION
ORGANIZING SENATOR HILL THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AB FIVE
SIXTY WOULD PROHIBIT INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES FROM USING
UTILITY RATES TO PAY FOR
EXPENSES INCURRED IN ASSISTING
OR DETERRING UNION ORGANIZING.
THESE ACTIVITIES SHOULD BE HELD
ENTIRELY AT THE EXPENSE OF
SHAREHOLDERS AND NOT OF RATE
PAYERS THERE IS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEAGUES ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BILL FIVE LARGEST. BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO I CHIANG I DALY. DODD
HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
BY. IT'S BURKE AYE HILL. AYE
HUESO AYE TITLE AYE JACKSON AYE
JONES. NO LEYVA BUY MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LOCK NO MERRELL NO NELSON. NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER BY STERN AYE
STONE NO I'M BURKE I HAVE A
COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GROVE I DON'T KNOW. BATES NO
FOR JUST NO. DALLY NO. FIVE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM TWO THIRTY SIX. SENATOR
RUBIO MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
TWENTY THREE BY SOME REMEMBER
ARAMBULA AN ACT GOING TO ORGAN
DONATION. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
WOULD ALLOW EMPLOYEES TO TAKE
ONE ADDITIONAL UNPAID LEAVE UP
TO THIRTY BUSINESS DAYS AND ONE
YEAR PERIOD. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ORGAN DONATION THE BILL ALSO
CLARIFIES THAT AN EMPLOYEE MUST
FIRST EXHAUST ALL AVAILABLE
SAFELY BEFORE TAKING ON PAID
LEAVE. NEARLY SIX THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED LIVING DONORS
TRANSPLANTS WERE PERFORMED LAST
YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO IN CALIFORNIA FOR MANY
PATIENTS AN ORGAN FAILURE AN
ORGAN TRANSPLANT CAN BE THEIR
ONLY REMAINING MEDICAL OPTION.
JOHN HOPKINS MEDICAL REPORTS
THAT FULL RECOVERY FROM ORGAN
DONATION TAKES ABOUT FOUR TO
SIX WEEKS WITH SOME PATIENTS
NEEDING MORE TIME. THAT SAID AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE WOULD ALSO
PROHIBIT INSURERS FROM
DECLINING RATINGS OR LIMITING
COVERAGE OF A PERSON UNDER A
LIFE OR DISABILITY INSURANCE
POLICY SOLELY DUE TO THE STATUS
OF THAT PERSON BEING. AT AN
ORGAN DONOR THIS BILL AIMS TO
REDUCE THE HURDLES OF ORGAN
DONATION BY INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF SURGICAL RECOVERY
TIME BY THIRTY DAYS OF UNPAID
LEAVE AND PROHIBITING
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST ORGAN
DONORS I'M ALSO AN ORGAN
REGISTERED PERSON AND I HOPE
EVERYONE REGISTERS AS WELL.
I'VE BEEN AN ADVOCATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EXAMPLE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROW COLORS OR ANY
OBJECTION. SEEING NINE EYES
FORTY. KNOWS IS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO THIRTY SEVEN. SENATOR LEYVA
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SIXTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND ACCOLADE
HEALING ARTS AND CLING THERE'S
THREATS TAKE EFFECT MERELY.
CENTER THEY'VE OTHER THAN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR WHICH WILL
REDUCE BARRIERS TO PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THROUGH
TELEHEALTH. THIS BILL CLARIFIES
EXISTING PRESCRIBING LAW
RELATED TO PRIOR EXAMINATION
AND WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIANS TO
SAFELY ACCESS PRESCRIPTIONS
LIKE BIRTH CONTROL VIA
TELEHEALTH TECHNOLOGY HAS
PROVIDED AN AVENUE FOR PATIENTS
TO ACCESS HEALTH CARE NO MATTER
WHERE THEY ARE. AND IN A WAY
THAT THEY WANT TO ACCESS CARE
RECOGNIZING THIS HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS HAVE CREATED WAYS TO
PROVIDE THE SAME STANDARD OF
CARE VIA TELEHEALTH FOR EXAMPLE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS USING
TELEHEALTH TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
BIRTH CONTROL BY PRESCRIBING
HORMONAL BIRTH CONTROL PILLS.
THREE SMARTPHONE APP RIGHT NOW
IN ORDER FOR A WOMAN TO ORDER
BIRTH CONTROL VIA A SMARTPHONE
APP SHE WAS FIRST SCHEDULE A
VIDEO CONFERENCE WHICH HAS
PROVEN TO BE A BARRIER THAT IS
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY. PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ESTIMATES THAT
NEARLY 50% OF ITS PATIENTS THAT
WOULD HAVE USES SERVICE FAILED
TO FULFILL THESE CURRENT
QUALIFICATIONS AND COULD NOT
ACCESS NEEDED BIRTH CONTROL. AB
TWELVE SIXTY FOURS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO INCREASE ACCESS OF
CARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS NO
MATTER WHERE THEY MAY LIVE BY
CLARIFYING THAT A SIMULTANEOUS
VIDEO VISIT IS NOT REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE HORMONAL BIRTH CONTROL
AS LONG AS IT IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE APPROPRIATE STANDARD
OF CARE. TELL HEALTH IS
EVOLVING AND AS POLICY MAKERS
WE MUST UPDATE CODE SECTIONS TO
REFLECT CHANGING TECHNOLOGY AND
DECREASE ARBITRARY BARRIERS TO
CARE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. THING MAN. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. BELL HI PORCHES.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG
BY DAILY. I DODD HI THERE ALSO
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES. BY LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MONNING
BY MORE LOCK. MORALE NO NIELSEN
NO PAN I PORTANTINO. HI ROTH
AYE RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN
AYE STONE. NUMBER BY. WHAT
COUNTY I WIENER. I WILL HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES. BURGESS I. MORE LOCK
STONE. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO TWO
KNOWS TO ON THE URGENCY. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS TO ON THE
MEASURE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
TWO FORTY TWO. SENATOR WIENER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY NO FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND
NATURAL AND TRANSPORTATION.
CENTER WIENER I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'M PRESENTING AB
SIXTY NO FIVE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT AUTHORIZES
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IF IT CHOOSES. TO
ESTABLISH A RESERVATION PROGRAM
TO BETTER CONTROL TRAFFIC ON
THE FAMOUSLY CROOKED LOMBARD
STREET OVER TWO MILLION PEOPLE
A YEAR OR VISIT THIS BLOCK OF
LOMBARD STREET THIS INCREASING
VOLUME OF VISITORS HAS CREATED
SIGNIFICAN SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS. BOTH FOR
VISITORS AND RESIDENTS OVER THE
PAST THREE YEARS OF LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY IN SAN
FRANCISCO HAS ENGAGED FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO DEVELOP POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS TO IMPROVE SAFETY AND
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR RESIDENTS
AND TO MAINTAIN. CHORUS STOCK
SENSE ACCESS TO A WORLD FAMOUS
ATTRACTION. THE BILL AS A
RESULT OF THIS MULTI YEAR
DISCUSSION I WOULD ALLOW THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO TO SET UP
A RESERVATION SYSTEM SO THAT
THE NUMBER OF CARS QUEUING IN
THE SURROUNDING BLOCKS WHICH
CAUSED SIGNIFICANT CONGESTION.
CAN BE REDUCED AND MANAGE THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED
A SUPPORT RESOLUTION RESOLUTION.
FOR THE BILL. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FROM RIVAL. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES NOBEL I PURCHASE NO
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG NO DALY NO DODD HI THERE
ALSO. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE
I JACKSON BY JONES. NO LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL BY MORNING
I'M MORE LUCK NO MORALE. NOPE
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER
OUR COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE NO MCGUIRE HI. ICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS ELEVEN MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO FORTY FOUR SENATOR
BELL MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AN ACT REALLY HOUSING.
CENTRE BELL THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
BUT PRESENT MEMBERS THIS BILL
EXTENDS THE AUTHORITY FOR SAN
JOSE TO BRIDGE JOB TO BE TO
BUILD EMERGENCY BRIDGE HOUSING
COMMUNITIES THE EXTENSION WILL
GO FROM JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE JANUARY OF FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. IT WILL
ALLOW TIME FOR THESE HOUSING
PROJECTS TO THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING FOR HOMELESS TO BE
BUILT ARJUN AYE VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS VOTE. SCENE NINE EYES
FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
ITEM TO TWO FORTY SEVEN.
SENATOR ALAN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AND NOT
GOING TO RESIDENTIAL REAL
PROPERTY. CENTER ON THE FLOOR
THIS IS A BILL OF HELP THE
ELLIS ACT THAT HAS NO
OPPOSITION. SO AS WHO WHO CAN I
THOUGHT I IN MANY CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS YELLS ACT
ESTABLISH PROCEDURES THAT
PUBLIC ENTITIES CAN IMPOSE UPON
OWNERS PRIOR TO A DRAWING
PROPERTY FROM THE RENTAL
MARKET. THE ACT ONLY APPLIES
WHEN AN OWNER SEEKS TO REMOVE
ALL UNITS FROM RENT OR LEASE IN
THE BUILDING OR ALL UNITS ON A
PROPERTY. WITH A BUILDING
CONTAINING THREE OR FEWER
YOU'LL UNITS SOME LANDLORDS
HAVE BEEN TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
AN AMBIGUITY IN THE ACT BY
REMOVING AND RE INTRODUCING
UNITS ONE BY ONE AND TO AVOID
THE ACT'S RESTRICTIONS. AND TO
EVADE RENT CONTROL LAWS. IF
LEFT UNCHECKED HI THIS ALLOWS A
LANDLORD EFFECTIVELY WITHDRAW
LESS THAN ALL THE UNITS FROM
THE RENTAL MARKET AND IN FACT
NEVER ACTUALLY LEAVE THE RENTAL
MARKET AT ALL WHILE STILL TWO
MILLION VICTORY ALL THE
TENANTS. FOR THIS BILL AMENDS
THE ACT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
THERE IS ONE AND ONLY ONE EXIT
DATE FOR ACCOMMODATIONS REMOVED
FROM THE MARKET FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THE ACT. THE DATE ON WHICH
THE FINAL TENDENCY AMONG ALL
THE TENANTS IN THE
ACCOMMODATIONS IS TERMINATED HI
THIS IS THIS IS THIS IS GOING
AFTER AND ROAD BEHAVIOR IT'S
THE REASON WHY. THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GET ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THOSE
THAT REPRESENT THE LANDLORDS
ONBOARD AS. A RESULT THE BILL
HAS NOT COULD OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECT YESTERDAY VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SING ON MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
HER SHE LED A AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES NOBEL HI BURGESS.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DALY DODD HI THERE ALSO.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TITLE BY JACKSON I JONES. NO
LEYVA. LEYVA THEY BY. MCGUIRE
BY MITCHELL. BY MONEY BY MORE
LOCK. NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN I. PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE NO I'M BURKE OUR COUNTY I
WIENER AYE WILK NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS PORGES.
CHIANG DALY NO THERE IS A HI.
PRICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO FIFTY EIGHT.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AN ACT
RELATING TO PROBATION. SENATOR
TO LETTER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT A BE
FOR THIRTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS AB FOR THIRTY
THREE REQUIRES THAT A
PROSECUTOR BE GIVEN TWO DAYS
WRITTEN NOTICE OF THE HEARING
FOR EARLY TERMINATION OF
PROBATION AND REQUIRES THE
PROSECUTOR TO NOTIFY THE VICTIM
IF THE VICTIM IS ASKED TO BE
NOTIFIED IN THE ABOVE CASE OR
ANY CASE. THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT THE VICTIMS HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK THE
RESTITUTION PROMISED TO THEM TO
THAT HE DISH PROCESS AND
ENTITLED TO THEM UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
IS SUPPORTED BY A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED AND THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION THE ABOVE REASONS A
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NINE MEMBERS WITHOUT IN ANY
OBJECTION WE CAN USE ANY
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTION. ISAAC FORTY KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SIXTY.
SENATOR SKINNER. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SYMBOL
FOR FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AN ACT WILLING TO
MIGRATORY BIRDS CENTER SKINNER.
I'M THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AB FOR FIFTY FOUR.
ADDRESSES A LOOPHOLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S WILDLIFE
PROTECTION LAW. AND AMENDMENTS
IN THE ASSEMBLY REMOVED THE
OPPOSITION FROM AGRICULTURE
GROUPS TIMBER HARVEST GROUPS
THE WIND IN THE SOLAR INDUSTRY
AND RESPECT. FEDERAL LAWS ARE
CURRENTLY TRYING TO UNDO SOME
OF CALIFORNIA'S IN AND NATIONAL
AND FEDERAL LAWS ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWS BUT MIGRATORY BIRDS WHICH
THIS BILL ADDRESSES BECAUSE IT
IS THE BY THE CALIFORNIA
MIGRATORY BIRD PROTECTION ACT.
MIGRATORY BIRDS ARE RECOGNIZED
IN CALIFORNIA LAWNCOURTS AS AN
IMPORTANT NATURAL RESOURCE AND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
ALLOWS CALIFORNIA PROTECT
BIRDS. AND AVOID CONFLICTS IN
LITIGATION THAT SURROUND THE
FEDERAL MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY
ACT SO WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CENTER MOORLACH. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M MAYBE
NEED SOME CLARIFICATION ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL A DOING A
LITTLE RESEARCH COMPANY CALLED
IN RG. IN THE MOHAWK HAS THE
MOJAVE SOLAR PLANT WHICH IS.
KILLING BIRDS IN FLIGHT IT'S
NINE HUNDRED DEGREES AND I EVEN
PAR AND WE GOT WIND FARMS. THAT
SHOW THE DATA THAT SHOWS THAT
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND BIRDS HAVE
BEEN KILLED PER YEAR SO I'M-
JUST TRYING TO. FIGURE OUT THIS
IS A RENEWABLE ENERGY PROJECTS
BOTH WOMEN SOLAR AND. NOW WE'RE
GONNA SUBJECT HIM TO CRIMINAL
CHARGES IF MY READING OR
UNDERSTANDING THE BILL IS
CORRECT. FOR AN INTENTIONAL
TAKING OF A SINGLE MIGRATORY
BIRD EVEN WHEN EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE. TO AVOID AND
MINIMIZE SUCH AN EVENT AND IT
IS CLEAR THAT THE PURPOSE OF
THE ACTIVITY IS NOT TO TAKE
BIRDS SO I'M I'M- TRYING TO
DETERMINE. IF WE DO WE SHUT
DOWN THESE ELECTRIC GENERATING
FACILITIES WHO WHO IS
CRIMINALIZED DOING CRIMINALIZED
THE PLANNING COMMISSIONERS THAT
APPROVED THE FACILITY IN THE
FIRST PLACE. YEAH AND SO I'M
JUST WONDERING WHERE IS THE
BALANCE BETWEEN ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND PROTECTING
MIGRATORY BIRDS WHICH IS
IMPORTANT BUT I'M I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THE
BALANCES SO. MAYBE THAT'S A
SPEECH OR MAYBE THE. FOR
MANAGER COULD RESPOND OF THOSE
ARE CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. YES WILL MAKE SURE
SHE DOES. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
SKINNER YOU MAKING COULD. THANK
YOU IN MY CLOTHES I WILL
ADDRESS THAT THERE WERE
CONCERNS WITH THE ORIGINAL THE
BILL AS ORIGINALLY SUBMITTED
CONCERNS BY THE ENERGY INDUSTRY
BOTH OIL WIND AND SOLAR AS WELL
AS SOME AGRICULTURE IN TIMBER
HARVEST GROUPS AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
REFLECT AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN ON
THE CHAMBER. I SOME OF THE OIL
INDUSTRIES AND THE AGRICULTURE
AS WELL AS THE SOLAR AND WIND
ENERGY. WHICH ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR AYE VOTE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN BY ACHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BELL I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG. DALY DOT BY THE RISE OF.
HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO. I TITLE BY
JACKSON HI JONES. NO LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK MORRELL NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH.
BY RUBIO AYE SKINNER I STERN
AYE STONE. NO BURKE I WILL
COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES.
FOR JUST NO. CHIANG DALY.
GROWTH NO MORE LOCK. WILK LOOK
NO. BATES NO. MORE LUCK NO.
PLEASE ALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CHIANG. DOLLY. PRICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO ITEM TWO
SIXTY TWO. SENATOR BATES. WILL
PASS ON THAT THAT ITEM. THAT
BRINGS US TO TWO SIXTY FIVE
SENATOR ALSO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
OH THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR DRAWS ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
TODAY HAVE THE PLEASURE
PRESENTING A. B. SEVEN ZERO
THREE. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
WHICH WOULD WAIVE TUITION AND
CERTAIN FEES FOR ANY
EXONERATING WHO ATTENDS ANY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA UP
TO TEN YEARS AFTER RELEASE.
EXONERATES MAY BE RELEASED BUT
LEFT SCARRED WITH THE MEMORIES
OF TRAUMA FROM BEING IMPRISONED
FOR A CRIME THEY DID NOT COMMIT.
THIS INCLUDES THE LOSS OF YEARS
OR DECADES OF THEIR LIFE THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN SPENT PURSUING
HIGHER EDUCATION JOB EXPERIENCE
AND A CAREER. EXONERATES ARE
FORCED TO START OVER 57% DO NOT
REACH THE INCOME LEVEL THAT
THEY EARNED BEFORE ENTERING
PRISON. THIS RESULTED ONE THIRD
OF EXONERATES BEING FINANCIALLY
DEPENDENT ON FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
THIS BILL WILL WAIVE TUITION
AND CERTAIN FEES THAT ARE
REQUIRED. AT ANY CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TEN
YEARS UPON RELEASE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE. SENATOR
ALLEN. I JUST WANT TO SAY THIS
A GREAT BILL I WISH I THOUGHT
OF IT YOU KNOW THE EXACT PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXONERATED SET BACKS SO
TREMENDOUSLY. AND ADD TO YOU
THIS IS THE LEAST WE CAN DO TO
HELP GET THEM BACK ON THEIR
FEET. AND I WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR AND OUR IN OUR GET
CENTER HERE FOR BRINGING IT TO
OUR ATTENTION. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. SEEING NONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE. I SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE UNANIMOUS VOTE ON THIS ITEM.
SEE NO OBJECTION I IS FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
ONE. SENATOR LEYVA. ARE YOU
PREPARED STIR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ A SYMBOL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
AND NOT GOING TO STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID AND CLING TO URGE
THE ROUTE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR LEYVA THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE AGAIN
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR THIS
BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE A
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THE SACK TO EXTEND
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION
DEADLINES UP TO THIRTY CALENDAR
DAYS FOR STUDENTS DUE TO
NATURAL DISASTERS OR
EMERGENCIES. AS YOU KNOW
FINANCIAL AID IS A CRUCIAL
COMPONENT TO STUDENT BEING ABLE
TO ACCESS HIGHER EDUCATION LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AT PUBLIC
COLLEGES IN CALIFORNIA CANNOT
AFFORD TO PAY FOR COLLEGE COSTS
WITH THEIR OWN RESOURCES AND
FINANCIALLY TO HELP STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES REACH THESE GAPS.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING EIGHT EIGHT
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION.
FORTY AYE. AYES FORTY KNOWS
THERE ON THE URGENCY AYE AYES
FORTY NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY TWO. SENATOR HILL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY EIGHT I ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN RELATIVE TO PUBLIC
UTILITIES. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND YOUR HEALTH THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT ACR SEVENTY
EIGHT WAS INTRODUCED IN
RESPONSE TO PACIFIC GAS
ELECTRIC'S JANUARY TWENTY NINTH
TWENTY NINETEEN FILING FOR
CHAPTER ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY. THIS
MEASURE ARTICULATES THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES AND
CALLS UPON REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
INCLUDE THOSE PRIORITIES IN ITS
FILINGS WITH THE UNITED STATES
BANKRUPTCY COURT IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AMONG THE
PRIORITIES ARE ENSURING THAT
ONE VICTIMS OF WILDFIRES CLAIMS
ARE RESOLVED PROMPTLY AND
EQUITABLY TO RANK AND FILE
EMPLOYEES CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
WAGES AND BENEFITS AND THREE
ENVIRONMENTAL MANDATES ARE
ACHIEVED AND RATES ARE STABLE
AND REASONABLE. THIS MEASURE
HAS NO OPPOSITION RECEIVE KNOWS
AS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEAGUES. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
RIGHT CASKEY MEN PRESENT I'M
UNABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION WHILE THERE'S MANY
THINGS THAT ARE DESIRABLE IN
THE RESOLUTION THE BANKRUPTCY
CODE IS QUITE CLEAR. THAT A
PLAN THAT'S PROPOSED IN GOOD
FAITH AND NOT FOR BEEN BY THE
LAW THAT DISCLOSES THE INSIDERS
THE TALKS ABOUT PAYMENTS. THAT
IT HAS IMPAIR CLASSES THAT ARE
MUST ACCEPT THE PLAN NOT
EVERYBODY PURCHASE IMPAIR CLASS
CLASSES FUNDS HE RECEIVED
LESSEN THAT THE WOODS ECEIVING
THE LIQUIDATION TO BE CONFIRMED
WILD THE LANGUAGE IN HERE.
TALKS ABOUT PRIORITIES
PRIORITIES SET BY UNITED STATES
CODE SECTION. FIVE OH SEVEN AND
NOT THE CITY CALIFORNIA AND-
WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING I WILL
BE STAYING OFF. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
MAN I ALSO ASSUME THAT YOU'RE
OBJECTING TO A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THIS ITEM. IT WILL TAKE
A ROLL CALL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN BY
OUR SHEILA. ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BILL I PURCHASED. BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO I CHIANG AYE DALY
AYE DODD. I THE RUSSELL.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO. HI TITLE I JACKSON BY
JONES. I LEYVA I'M ACQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK I AM A REAL AYE NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE AYE AMBERG OUR CASKEY
NO WIENER AYE WILK. HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS A
LETTER HI. GORGEOUS. THERE ARE
SO HI GLAZER HI GROWTH. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE IS ADOPTED THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MOVING
ON TO ITEM TWO EIGHTY EIGHT.
SENATOR MCGUIRE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT NINETY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES. FOR IS YOUR SENATOR
MCGUIRE A GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE RISEN AB
EIGHT NINE NINE ON BEHALF OF
THE GOOD DOCTOR DOCTOR WOULD
WHICH REMOVE THE BURDENSOME BAY
AREA FOR COMMUNITY CLINICS. IN
INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA. THE BILL
REQUIRES THE. S. H. PD TO
EMPANEL A COMMUNITY CLINICS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE BY JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY. AND
WHEN DEVELOPING CONSTRUCTION
STANDARDS TO CONSIDER UNIQUE IN
DISTRICT NEEDS A PRIMARY CARE
CLINICS IN CONTRAST WAS
FACILITIES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
HOSPITAL PROVIDING A HIGHER
LEVEL OF CARE. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE. I IS
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO NINETY. SENATOR
RUBIO. WE'RE GONNA HAVE PASS
THAT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER TWO
NINETY TWO. SENATOR PORTANTINO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN
AND ACT REALLY INTIMATE
MATERNAL HEALTH SENATOR
PORTANTINO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS SIDE RISE TO PRESENT AB
FIVE SEVEN SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EGGMAN IT'S CLEAR THAT
MATERNAL HEALTH IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
AND A KEY ASPECT OF OUR SOCIAL
SAFETY NET AB FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
WOULD ENSURE CONTINUITY OF CARE
FOR NEW MOTHERS DEALING WITH
THE MATERNAL HEALTH DISORDERS.
OR LOSING THEIR EXTENDED MEDIC
CAL ELIGIBILITY UNDER CURRENT
LAW AB FIVE SEVEN SEVEN ALLOWS
WOMEN DIAGNOSED WITH MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION REMAIN
WITH THEIR TREATING HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER FOR UP TO TWELVE
MONTHS FROM THE TIME OF
DIAGNOSIS ENSURING THAT THEY
RECEIVE CONTINUITY OF CARE WITH
A TRUSTED PROVIDER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
UMBERG. LOOKING FURTHER FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING ANY UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE. I IS
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER. TWO FORTY TWO NINETY
THREE SENATOR UMBERG MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FORTY SIX BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
AND REDISTRICTING AND ACCORDING
TO THE PUBLIC OR FORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. SENATOR
UMBERG THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM MADAM PRESIDENT
THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEES ANNUAL
OMNIBUS BILL EVERYBODY LIKES IT
I HEARD AND I VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE. IT'S
THE ROCK. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NINE. EYES FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
NINETY FIVE. SENATOR ALLEN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS ON THAT.
OKAY. SENATOR DR SO IS THIS
YOUR BILL. TWO NINETY FIVE TO
NINETY FOUR. YOU SKIP.
SCRUNCHED UP GET SCRATCHED OUT
IF YOU WANT TO TAKE IT UP I
HAVE A. OKAY. OKAY THIS IS WHAT
YOU WANT OKAY. SENATOR SENATOR
DORADO. YES. WHAT LET'S IF I
COULD JUST TAKE A BREAK VERY
QUICKLY
. THE NEXT ITEM IS TO
NINETY FIVE SENATOR ALLEN ARE
YOU PREPARED TO DO 2% ON THIS
ITEM. CAME. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AND ACT
REALLY IN A BUSINESS. SENATOR
ALLEN. FLOOR IS YOURS WELL I A
IT APPEARS THAT THEY WOULD LIKE
ME TO PASS ON FILE I'M SO I
WOULD LOVE I'M SORRY THAT. WE
WILL PASS ON THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM. MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
TWO NINETY SEVEN. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
AWAIT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU AN
ACT RELATING TO DRINKING WATER.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE FOR THE
VERY MUCH A MAN PRESIDENT TO
THIS MEASURE A. B. FIVE OH
EIGHT BILLS ON THE
EXTRAORDINARY PROGRESS WE HAVE
MADE OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. TO PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING
WATER TO DO MANAGE COMMUNITIES
WHO RELY ON SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
AND DOMESTIC WELLS SPECIFICALLY
THIS MEASURE REQUIRES THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
TO ALERT RESIDENTS ABOUT WATER
CONTAMINATION IN THE AREA THE
HEALTH RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
SUCH CONTAMINATION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CONSOLIDATION
OR EXTENSION OF WATER SERVICE.
THESE CHANGES TO THE BOARDS
CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY WILL
GIVE COMMUNITY MEMBERS THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO ENGAGE
IN EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD WATER QUALITY
SOMETHING THAT IS SO IMPORTANT
TO US ALL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. THERE NIELSEN. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
OF THE SENATE THIS KIND OF HAS
A LONG STORY BEHIND IT IT DOES
WHEN THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT LEGISLATION
PASSED TO A FEW YEARS AGO IT
WAS. ADAMANTLY REPORTED THAT
DOMESTIC WELLS WERE NOT GOING
TO BE INCLUDED. THAT I
PREDICTED THAT THEY WOULD BE.
AND HERE'S A BACK DOOR WAY
YEARS LATER. OF PUTTING
DOMESTIC WELLS UNDER REGULATION
THEY WERE TOLD THEY WERE NOT
GOING TO HAVE TO CONTEND WITH.
IT IS AN EXPANSION OF AUTHORITY
THAT I BELIEVE IS UNJUSTIFIED
ORIGINAL VOTE. ANY IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN SENATOR HERTZBERG YOU
YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
SPECIFIC POINT THAT WAS RAISED
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
NOT ONLY IS THIS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE.
BUT ALSO THIS BILL CLARIFIES
THAT THE WATER BOARD CANNOT
ORDER CONSOLIDATION EXTENSION
OF SERVICE UNTIL THE LAND OVER
AND ORDER AFFECTED AND THE AND
AFFECTED RESIDENTS PROVIDE
WRITTEN CONSENT THIS IS A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS BUT IT
DEALS WITH THE VERY SENSITIVE
DYNAMIC THAT WE HAVE NOW DEALT
WITH IN THE LAST NUMBER OF
BILLS OVER THE YEARS
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES. ARE TO BE ABLE TO
DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY ASK RIVAL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. NO BILL I
PURCHASED NO BRADFORD HI KELLY
AT ALL. CHIANG. DALY NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
TOTAL. JACKSON. I JONES NO
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL
BY MONEY. I'M MORE LOCK MORALE
NO NIELSEN NO PAN I PORTANTINO
HI ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE NO NUMBER. I
HAVE A COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK
NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CARRIER. CHIANG TITLE
MORE LOCK. THE. ICE TWENTY
SEVEN NO NIGHT KNOWS KNOWS NINE
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO NINETY NINE. SENATOR PAN
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL AND ACT REALLY INTO
HEALTH FACILITIES. SENATOR PENN
THE FLOORS YEARS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS SOME
PLEASE PRESENT AT TEN FOURTEEN
BY SOME MEMBER DONALD WHICH HAS
TO DEAL WITH. OUR LOCAL
HOSPITALS WHO OF COURSE ARE AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT RESOURCE
FOR COMMUTER NOT JUST
BUSINESSES THEY ARE DEFINITELY
COMMUNITY. RESOURCES AB TEN
FORTY REQUIRES HOSPITALS
PROVIDE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAY NOTICE TO THE PUBLIC
PRIOR TO A PLANNED REDUCTION.
OR ELIMINATION OF EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES. THE DECISION
BY HOSPITALS REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE SERVICES CAN CREATE
SERIOUS CHALLENGES FOR A
COMMUNITY. THE FACT IN THE
AUTHORS DISTRICT LAST YEAR TO
CAN BE HOSPITAL OF LONG BEACH
CLOSED ITS DOORS AFTER PROBABLY
DIVERTING EMERGENCY ROOM
PATIENTS TO OTHER HOSPITALS.
THIS WAS DONE WITH VERY LITTLE
NOTICE THE RESIDENTS IN VERY
LITTLE TIME TO ENGAGE THE
HOSPITAL PROVIDER ON
ALTERNATIVE TO CLOSURE. AS A
RESULT PATIENTS NOW EXPERIENCE
LONGER WAITING TIMES FOR
SERVICES LONGER AMBULANCE
TRAVEL TIMES AND OVERCROWDING
AT OTHER HOSPITALS IN EMERGENCY
ROOMS. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
EXPERIENCE IS NOT UNIQUE TO
LONG BEACH IS PREVALENT UP AND
DOWN THE STATE IS MORE
HOSPITALS CLOSE ARE CHOOSING
SOLIDI I THINK PARTICULARLY IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES. AB TEN
FOURTEEN WILL PROVIDE COMMITTEE
HERE'S WHAT THE OPPORTUNITY BY
GIVEN MORE TIME TO FULLY
INVESTIGATE. AND THEN IF I
OTHER OPTIONS INCLUDING
POTENTIALLY SECURING A NEW-PROVIDER TO PREVENT THE CLOSURE
OF A CRITICAL HOSPITAL. AT THE
VERY LEAST THIS BILL ALLOWS
PATIENTS AND RESIDENTS TO
BETTER PREPARE FOR THEIR NEXT
EMERGENCY WHEN THEIR LOCAL
HOSPITAL IS CLOSED. THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CENTER STONE THANK YOU
MATTER PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF AB TOWN
ONE FOR. THIS MIGHT NEED SOME
MEDICINE. WELL WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
BILL AB TEMAN FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE'S PUT A LOT OF
REGULATIONS ON HOSPITALS AND A
LOT OF NEW MANDATES ON
HOSPITALS ESPECIALLY. IN AREAS
WHERE WE SEE SIGNIFICANT
HOMELESS POPULATIONS THEY HAVE
TO BASICALLY BABY SET THE
HOMELESS IN THE EMERGENCY ROOMS
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THIRTY
DAYS OF MEDICINE WHEN THEY
LEAVE MAKE SURE THEY HAVE A
DESTINATION TO WHERE THEY HAVE
TO GO AND MANY OF THESE
HOSPITALS TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ARE BLEEDING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS A MONTH. AND MAKING
A AN EXECUTIVE DECISION TO
CLOSE AN EMERGENCY ROOM DOWN IF
THEY'RE PART OF A CHAIN IN
ORDER TO KEEP THE OTHER URGENCY
ROOMS OPEN THROUGHOUT THEIR
RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS ARE
GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS SO WE NEED
TO LET THE HOSPITAL'S MAKE THE
BEST DECISION THAT THEY CAN IN
ORDER TO KEEP THE DOORS OF THE
REMAINING FACILITIES UP
CERTAINLY CONSOLIDATION MAY BE
A GOOD THING ECONOMICALLY FOR
HOSPITALS BUT- WE CAN EXPECT A
HOSPITAL TO BLEED. A WEEK AFTER
WEEK MONTH AFTER MONTH BECAUSE
WE'RE FIGHTING MANDATE THAT THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE HOMES
POP PLACE. AND THAT THEY
REALLY. DID NOT CREATE. AND THE
AMOUNT UNCOMPENSATED CARE. THAT
THEY HAVE TO PROVIDE NOT ONLY
BY STATE LAW BY FEDERAL LAW. WE
NEED THE HOSPITALS HAVE THE
ECONOMY TO DO WITHIN THEIR
FINANCIAL BEST INTEREST TO
CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK THAT
THEY DO AND PROVIDING QUALITY
HEALTHCARE FOR. ALL OF OUR
POPULATION THE COULD IN THE
INDIGENT POPULATION HOW WE
CANNOT HAMSTRING THEM FOR SOME
TO TAKE A LOSS FOR THOSE
REASONS I REQUEST A NO VOTE ON
A. B. TEN ONE FOUR. SENATOR
DODD. A YES QUESTION BEFORE
MANAGER PLEASE. SENATOR PAN
WOULD YOU ACCEPT YES I'D BE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS YEAH
ONE OF THE KIDS CONCERNS THAT'S
BEEN PRESENTED TO BE ON THIS
BILL I THINK IS WHAT IS
RIGHTEOUS BUT I WOULD VALUE
YOUR EXPERIENCE IN IN IN THESE
AREAS. THAT YOU KNOW IF I IF I
HOSPITAL IT DOES HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION TO CLOSE HAVING A SIX
THE SIX MONTH NOTICE WOULD
PERHAPS BRING A NUMBER OF
DOCTORS OR AND OR NURSES YEAH
WE HAVE STAFFING RATIOS AND
HOSPITALS ALL SAID AND WILL
RESIGN BECAUSE LOOK AT THEY'VE
GO A FAN FOR THEMSELVES AND GO
TO WORK. YO SOUGHT SOMEWHERE
ELSE SO I WORRY ABOUT THE AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF A
BILL LIKE THIS AND WHAT IT DOES
TO STAFFING ISSUES. EVER
ALREADY TOUGH SITUATION.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION FROM
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM NAPA I
WOULD SAY FIRST OF ALL OF
COURSE CERTAINLY A CLOSURE ANY
ANNOUNCED THE CLOSURE WHETHER
IT'S A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS OR-
TWO DAYS. WILL BE DESTRUCTIVE
FOR THE STAFFING RIGHT I THINK
WHAT WE WANT IN THIS CASE WITH
THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY TO GIVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO HOSPITAL WORK
TOGETHER SAY IS THERE. A
POSSIBILITY OF AN ALTERNATIVE
RIGHT AND I THINK IN ENGAGING.
ANSWERED THE STAFF WILL BE PART
OF THAT DISCUSSION AS WELL
AFTER ALL DISPOSITIONS TO HAVE
ADMITTING PRIVILEGES. AT THE
HOSPITAL WILL WANT TO BE SURE
THAT THOSE SERVICES ARE STILL
AVAILABLE AND- IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO DEVELOP A SOLUTION
FOR PROVIDING THE SERVICES WE
NEED TO HAVE YOU SURE THERE'S
THE TIME FRAME FOR DOING THAT
SO CERTAINLY I RECOGNIZE THE
CONCERN THAT YOU RAISE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED IN OUR- COMMITTEE AS
WELL BUT I ALSO WITH. IS THAT.
HAVE A YOU KNOW THAT. GIVEN
NOTICE CERTAINLY TWELVE. IS THE
SERVING ON PEOPLE GO AWAY ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN ALSO
GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY THEN TO
HAVE THE KIND OF CONVERSATIONS.
TO TRY TO SEE WHETHER THERE'S
AN ALTER THE SIMPLY JUST
CLOSING THAT EMERGES FROM
ESPECIALLY IN A RURAL COMMUNITY
MAYBE THE ONLY HOSPITAL FOR A
VERY LONG. WAY AWAY AND I THINK
THAT THE COMMUNITY COMING
TOGETHER KNOWING THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING GOING ON. IS GIVES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO SAVE
THOSE SERVICES AND THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR DODD. FOLLOW UP
QUESTION. SENATE MAN JOHN. OKAY
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER I
THINK IT IS ADDRESSED QUESTION.
THAT COULD BE AN EXAMPLE OF WHY
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE IT WOULD A
BIT SPECIFIC EXAMPLE WHY THIS
BILL WOULD HAVE BEEN IMPORTANT
AND WHY THIS BILL IS NECESSARY.
WELL AS I AM. ENTER PAN IF I
COULD WILL GET THROUGH THE REST
OF THE QUESTIONS AND THEN YOU
CAN USE USE YOUR CONCLUSION TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. AT CENTER
DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I JUST WANT
TO COMMENT THAT YOU KNOW
EMERGENCY ROOMS WERE FACED
WITH. THESE ISSUES. IN OUR VERY
RULE PARTS OF THE OF THE STATE
BUT- THIS IS GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM THE PROBLEM IS. THAT
EMERGENCY ROOMS WERE FOR MERGES
CITIES AND THEY BECOME A PLACE
WHERE IT'S PRIMARY. CARE IS
GIVEN AND THE ACA WAS SUPPOSED
TO ADDRESS THAT AND IT HASN'T
QUITE FRANKLY. TO THE CHALLENGE
FOR A LOT OF THE RULE HOSPITALS
IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW YOU
CAN KEEP THE DOORS OPEN. AND
ONE OF THE WAYS IS BECAUSE IT
BECAME THE PRIMARY CARE YOUR
EMERGENCY ROOM IT'S DRAINING
THE REST OF THE HOSPITAL. AND
SO THEY CLOSED EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT DOWN SO THEY CAN
SUSTAIN THE REST OF THE
HOSPITAL SO THIS BILL IS NOT
GOING TO FIX THE PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE WITH. EMERGENCY ROOMS
GOING OUT OF BUSINESS THE
PROBLEM IS SOMEWHERE ELSE THE
PROBLEM IS THAT WE'RE USING OUR
PRIMARY CARE THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE ARE USING. THEIR MERGES
THE ROOM FOR THE PRIMARY CARE.
AND WHEN YOU GO TO AN EMERGENCY
ROOM THEY THE HOSPITAL DOESN'T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY SAY. WELL
WE'VE SEEN YOU FIVE TIMES THIS
MONTH FOR THE SAME THING AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE USE EMERGENCY
ROOM. AS A SOCIAL VISIT QUITE
FRANKLY I MY COUSIN WHO. YOU'VE
MET ON THE FLOOR HERE SERVED IN
EMERGENCY ROOMS I TALKED HIM
ALL THE TIME ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
IN THE EMERGENCY ROOMS. THERE
FOR EMERGENCIES NOT FOR YOUR
PRIMARY CARE THAT IS THE
PROBLEM AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM
WE NEED TO DRESS. THIS BILL IS
NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE OUTCOME
OF PEOPLE TRYING TO MAKE A
BUSINESS WORK. THAT IS
REGULATED DID THAT REGULATE
ENVIRONMENT IS BECAUSE THEM SO
I HEARD YOU KNOW BUT WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY. WORK ON THE PROBLEM.
AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT WE HAVE
TOO MANY PEOPLE USE EMERGES
ROOM. AND IS NOT AN EMERGENCY
WE NEED TO HAVE THEM. USE THEIR
OFFICE VISIT TIME IN THOSE
AREAS TO GET THEIR HEALTH.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. YES I JUST
WANT TO THINK AS SENATOR PLAN
FOR FLOOR MANAGING THIS BECAUSE
COMING FROM LONG BEACH WHERE WE
DID HAVE COMMUNITY HOSPITAL
CLOSE NOT TOO LONG AGO THIS
EXTENSION ENABLED US TO RE
NEGOTIATE A FINANCING PLAN WE
ENTERED INTO A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WITH WAS FORMALLY
MOLINA HEALTH CARE OF A BRAND
NEW A BELIEVE IT'S M. W. AND
WHO IS THE NEW FINANCING
PARTNER WITH THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH CREATIVE FINANCING ALSO
ALLOWED US TO DISCUSS NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NURSES
ESPECIALLY REGISTERED NURSES
THAT. DIDN'T KNOW IF THEY WOULD
BE RELOCATED OR NOT AND THIRDLY
IT ENABLED US TO ADD A SO BRING
BEDS IN MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHICH I THINK WAS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY BUT HAVING THAT
EXTRA TIME I THINK WILL ENABLE.
US TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THIS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE SHOULD ANOTHER
HOSPITAL A CLOSE SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THAT AND
THANK YOU FOR. A PATRICK
O'DONNELL AS WELL FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. SENATOR NIELSEN.
BETTER PRESENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE THIS IS
KIND OF A LONG TERM ISSUE THAT
HAS. POPPED UP IN NO SMALL
MEASURE BECAUSE OF POLICIES THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
EXAMPLE REALIGNMENT. WHICH
DUMPED THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD AREADY BEEN IN
CUSTODY IN CALIFORNIA AND IN
TREATMENT. INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
MANY WITH MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS THAT REQUIRE ATTENTION.
AND WHERE DO THEY SHOW UP. THE
ER. I HAD POLLS OVER THE PAST
YEARS FROM YOUR HEAD NURSES
SAYING. THE PRISON JUST PULLED
UP. WITH THE BUS. AND DUMPED
OFF A PAROLE WE- WHO IS
DESTABILIZED. AND IS DANGEROUS
AND WE HAVE HIM HERE. IN THE ER.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE CAPABILITY.
THE TRAINING OR THE FACILITIES
TO DEAL WITH THESE KINDS OF
INDIVIDUALS THEN PRESENTS
DANGER. OFTEN SAFETY AND
PROTECTION THE PATIENTS THE
STAFF THE DOCTORS. EVERYBODY AT
THAT FACILITY. WE'VE GOT A HAD
THE IRONIC OPPOSITE. IN
PARADISE BUT WE LOST A HOSPITAL
BUT THE E. R. WAS RETAINED. IT
DIDN'T BURKE. THAT THAT'S VERY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DEAL WITH HERE. AND
THERE ARE REAL CONCERNS. A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO I VOTED FOR
BILL AYE FORMALLY NEVER WOULD
HAVE SUPPORTED HERE. ALLOWING A
E. R. DR TO IMPOSE A FIFTY ONE
FIFTY HOLD. WHY WOULD I WANT TO
VOTE YES ON SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE TRAINING
TO DEAL WITH THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THEY DON'T
HAVE THE FACILITIES IN THE
CAPABILITY TO DEAL WITH ONE.
HOWEVER I HAD TO ACCEPT THAT
THERE THERE. BECAUSE OF THE
ACTIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE THEY
ARE THERE. AND THEY ARE
PROBLEMS. NOW THAT PROBLEM DOES
NOT GET SOLVED WITH THIS. I
WOULD URGE A NO VOTE. IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WE
HAVE A HOSPITAL ORANGE COUNTY
THAT. ATTENTION ABOUT EMERGENCY
ROOMS YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN
AMAZING. AMOUNT OF BACK UP
SUPPORT FOR HEART ATTACKS FOR
STROKES YOU NEED A LOT OF
STAFFING WITH THE ATTACHED
HOSPITAL. IN IT IT DOES BECOME
VERY DIFICULT AND WE HAVE THE
CITY A IN THE CITY OF US THANK
MANY FELLOW FRUSTRATED THAT TO
AN EMERGENCY ROOMS CLOSE THEY
REZONE THE SILLY AS EMERGENCY
ROOM ALL ME TO THE HOSPITAL HAD
A CLOSE EVERYTHING. AND SO THIS
BUILDING WONDERFUL FACILITY%
JUST SITS WITH A GREEN FENCE
AROUND IT BEING. NOT USE SO IT.
PROPERTY HOSPITAL'S VERY THIN
PROFIT MARGIN IF AT ALL WHEN I
WAS SERVED ON THE CAL OPTIMA
BOARD FOR FOUR YEARS SAID IT'S
A COUNTY OPERATIVE HEALTH
SYSTEM WE HAD ONE HOSPITAL THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY. DRIVE OVER TO
OUR OFFICES EVERY WEEK TO GET
THEIR PAYMENTS SO THEY COULD
PUT IT IN THE BANK AND START
PAYING BILLS SO WHAT ARE WE
GONNA BE REAL CAREFUL WITH
HOSPITALS IN. AND WHAT WE'RE
PUTTING ON THEIR BACKS WHEN
THEY'RE READY STRUGGLING SITE.
I URGE A NO VOTE. ON A. B. TEN
FOURTEEN. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATE
BILL. BETTER PRESIDENT THE THIS
SATURDAY WE HAD A SITUATION
WHERE WE HAD TO HOSPITALS THE
TOWN ROAD MEDICAL PATIENTS ONE
WAS THE COUNTY HOSPITAL VALLEY
MEDICAL CENTER WHICH IS THE
LARGEST SO A PUBLIC HOSPITAL IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
THE SECOND ONE WAS O'CONNOR
HOSPITAL. AND BY ALLOWING MORE
TIME. IN TERMS OF NOTICE OF
CLOSURE IT GIVES THE COUNTY OF
ESPECIALLY MORE TIME TO ADJUST
TO HANDLING THE INCREASED AND
MEDI CAL PATIENTS AND I THINK
THIS BILL IS A GOOD BILL WE
SHOULD SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE
SAID INVOLVES HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF MEDI CAL
PATIENTS CARE THE COST TO THE
OUT OF THE NEEDS TO BE. TAKEN
IN CONSIDERATION THE BILL WILL
SAVE MONEY IT WILL SAVE THE
STATE MONEY ANALYSTS SAY THE
COUNTY HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS MONEY
OF OVER THE LARGE NUMBER MEDI
CAL PATIENTS IN OUR COUNTY WERE
SERVED WELL BY THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS EVENTUALLY
PURCHASING O'CONNOR HOSPITAL
FOR USE BY THE COUNTY. AND WE
CUT WE CONSUMMATED THAT
AGREEMENT THIS YEAR SO I REGION
I VOTE ON THOSE THIS WILL HELP
PRESERVE THE BASIC SAFETY NET
HOSPITALS THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA PLUS THE BASIC
ACUTE CARE EMERGENCY ROOMS. WE
NEED TO HAVE ARJUN AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THING NINE SENATOR PAN
YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS I
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST DEBATE WE
HAD ON THIS BILL I WANT TO
THANK A GOOD FRIEND FROM LONG
BEACH FOR SHARING HER
EXPERIENCES A SAID THE AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL UP PART OF WHAT
PROMPTED THIS BILL AS THE
EXPERIENCE OF THAT CAN BE
HOSPITAL LONG BEACH CLOSING ITS
DOORS OUT SOMEONE. THAT I THINK
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM HAS A ALSO
SHARED HIS EXPERIENCE WITH
HOSPITAL CLOSURE IN HIS
DISTRICT I'VE I DO WANT TO
RESPOND TO. GOOD FRIENDS A
REGARDING SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED. ABOUT THIS
BILL FIRST OF ALL. I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT. THAT DURING THE
FIRES RIGHT THE LOS THE
HOSPITAL PARADISE. IN FACT WE
AND I WAS PROUD TO SUPPORT
LEGISLATION HERE AND THIS
SENATE. SPECIAL ALLOW AN
EMERGENCY ROOM TO RE OPEN.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT. THEY
DIDN'T REALLY QUITE HAVE THE
FULL HOSPITAL THERE BECAUSE THE
HOUSE WAS BURNED DOWN. AND I
THINK THAT SPEAKS TO THE VITAL
ROLE THAT MERGES ROOM PLAYS IN
THE COMMUNITY THE FACT THAT WE
ACTUALLY. KERRY Là HAD
LEGISLATION HERE. TO ACTUALLY
SAY THAT WE CAN ALLOW WE NEED
TO HELP THE ALLOW HOSTILE TO RE
OPEN AND EMERGENCY ROOM A
COMMUNITY THAT WITH THIS. BY
FIRE EVEN THOUGH THEY DIDN'T
HAVE ALL THE COMPONENTS A
NECESSARILY NEEDED AND WE
FIGURED THAT OUT AND I WANT TO
THANK MIKE. A GOOD FRIEND FROM
TO HIM FOR CHAMPIONING THAT AND
TO WORK WITH HIM ON ON THAT
ISSUE BUT I THINK THAT ALSO
SPEAKS TO WHY WE NEED THIS
LEGISLATION AS WELL. IN TERMS
OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT THE
RESEARCH STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT THE STATE'S THAT
ACCIDENTAL. THE MEDI CAL
EXPANSION IN THE FULL A CA. HE
HAD FEWER HOSPITAL CLOSURES.
PARTICULARLY RURAL COMMUNITIES
THE STATE THAT HAVE IT. WE ARE
WE. ARE SEEING RURAL HOSPITALS
CLOSE. AND THAT'S IT. AND IN
FACT MANY OF THEM ARE THE ONLY
PROVIDERS FOR LARGE AREAS AND
IN FACT THE ACA HAS ALLOWED
MORE THOSE HOSPITAL STAY OPEN.
DO WE STILL HAVE A PROBLEM YES
WE DO. AND I KNOW MY GOOD.
FRIEND FROM THE TO MACULA AND I
HAVE WORK TO TRY TO IMPROVE
PAYMENT RATES RIGHT BECAUSE-
THIS I SIMPLY I DON'T THIS
BILL SIMPLY. RIGHTS MORE TIME.
FOR TO MUSIC COME TOGETHER TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM. YES THERE
ARE UNDERLYING ISSUES WE'VE
WRESTLED WITH SO THOSE RIGHT
HERE IN THE STATE SENATE. BUT
WE ALSO NEED THAT TIME FOR THEM
TO WORK TOGETHER AND AGAIN THAT
THE L. SPEAKING TO THE STAFFING
ISSUES AND THE OTHER THINGS. WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT TIME FOR
COMMUNITIES BILL TO COME
TOGETHER. YES THERE'S MORE
THINGS FOR US TO DO HERE IN THE
STATE SENATE HELP SUPPORT
HOSPITAL TO KEEP THEM OPEN. AND
WE HAVE DONE SOME OF THOSE AND
YES WE SHOULD DO MORE. BUT THE
SAME TIME WHEN THE HOSPITAL'S
ABOUT THE CLOTHES WE ALSO NEED
TO GIVE THAT LOCAL COMMUNITY
OPPORTUNITY. AND THE TIME TO BE
ABLE TO COME UP WITH A SOLUTION
AND MAYBE EVEN APPEAL TO ONE OF
US OF ITS ONE HAPPENED TO BE IN
OUR AREA. TO SAY HEY CAN DO
SOMETHING OTHER HELP WE CAN DO
JUST LIKE WE DID FOR. THE AT
THE E. R. AND IN PARADISE THAT
WE CAN HELP TRY TO KEEP THAT.
WE ARE OPEN. SO WITH THAT AGAIN
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
SPOKE ON THE BILL I TONIGHT
VOTES. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
NOBEL I PURCHASED NO BRADFORD I
CAN BE AT ALL I CHIANG. DALY NO
DOT NO THREAT SO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ BY GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL. HUESO HI
TITLE BY JACKSON I JONES. NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
AYE MONNING. BY MORE LOCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN. I STONE NO
NUMBER PILOT CASSIE I WINNER BY
WILK BY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN HI. CHANGE.
GLAZER HI HILL BY. RUBIO HI.
ICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE OH FOUR. SENATOR MINING
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FORTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AN ACT
RELATING TO WELL I GUESS
SENATOR MINING THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN FORTY
UPDATES LAWSON NATIONALLY
ENACTED IN THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES. GOVERNING OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA TO
ENSURE THAT THE DIVISION OF OIL
GAS AND GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES
ALSO KNOWN AS DR GIVES PRIMARY
CONSIDERATION TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
WHEN MAKING OIL WELL PERMITTING
DECISIONS. OTHER STATE NATURAL
RESOURCES ENTITIES HAVE A CLEAR
MISSION TO PRIORITIZE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT AB
FOURTEEN FORTY WILL DO THE SAME
FOR DR. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW I REPRESENT
A DISTRICT THAT HAS ABOUT 75%
OF THE STATE'S OIL IS PRODUCED
FOR CALIFORNIANS AND SO I THINK
WHEN I GET UP AND SPEAK ABOUT
OIL PEOPLE THINK IT'S SELF
CENTERED OR SELF SERVING
BECAUSE MY DISTRICT ACTUALLY
THRIVES ON AN ECONOMY THAT'S
OIL DRIVEN BUT DOING SOME DATA
RESEARCH HIGH FOUND OUT. THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
ACTUALLY REDUCED THE PERMITS
REQUIRED FOR DRILLING AND
CONSERVE OIL PRODUCTION. IS
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY DOWN
EIGHTY PER OR SEES ME 40% SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY. BUT THE
CONSUMPTION RATE FOR
CALIFORNIANS HAS GONE UP OVER
TWENTY TWO PERCENT. AND SO WHEN
YOU THINK IF YOU'RE NT
DRILLING FOR OIL IN PRODUCING
OIL INTO THE GREATEST MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY STRICT.
REGULATORY PROCESSES IN WHERE
DOES THE OIL COME FROM THAT WE
CALIFORNIANS IN ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS CONSUME. IT COMES
FROM IRAQ ECUADOR IN SAUDI
ARABIA. AND TO IMPORT THAT OIL
INTO OUR COAST THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY WHEN THIS THESE
VESSELS LAND. A WE EXPORT ABOUT
A HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
VESSELS THAT COME TO UNITED
STATES VIA SAUDI ARABIA ECUADOR
AND IRAQ. AND WHEN I THINK OF
THE HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS IN
THESE COUNTRIES THE ATTACKS ON
WHAT PEOPLE IN THIS COMMUNITY
SWEAR TO DEFEND THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY WOMEN BARELY GOT
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSES IN
SAUDI ARABIA BUT THEY STILL
CAN'T EVEN DRIVE WITHOUT A MALE
ESCORT. WE DON'T ACTUALLY FUNDS
THOSE THINGS BUT WE ACTUALLY
SEND THE MONEY IN A QUICK
EQUIVALENT TO ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS PER
VESSEL AGAIN TWO HUNDRED
VESSELS A YEAR. BECAUSE
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE DECREASED OUR
OIL PRODUCTION HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
INCREASED CONSUMPTION AS
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU THINK AS THE DECLINE
IN THE KEY IN THE PRODUCTION OF
OIL IT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT AND
AGAIN PRODUCING OIL OUTSIDE OF
THIS STATE WHICH IS PRODUCED
WITHOUT. A REFERENCE OR
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT OR PRODUCED OUTSIDE
OR WITHOUT REFERENCE TO CIVIL
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS. WAGES
ANYTHING THIS BILL PARTICULARLY
WILL RESTRICT SOME OF THAT AND
TO LOOK AT AN AGENCY THAT IS
INDUSTRY FUNDED DOCTOR IS
COMPLETELY FUNDED BY THE OIL
INDUSTRY. VIA S. SURCHARGE THIS
ISSUE TO THEM. IT'S HAVE
ACTUALLY GONE DOWN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE FOR
HARVESTING OR FOR GATHERING OR
PRODUCING OIL WHERE THE PERMITS
HAVE GONE UP IS BECAUSE OF THE
BILL THAT WAS PASSED A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO THAT REQUIRES DOT
OIL COMPANIES TO ABANDON WELLS.
AND SO THEY HAVE TO PULL A
PERMIT TO ABANDON WELLS AND
BRING THEM INTO COMPLIANCE
WITHIN A TWENTY FOUR MONTH
PERIOD. AND SO THAT'S WHERE THE
PERMIT INCREASE HAS TAKEN PLACE
IT'S NOT A NEW PRODUCTION OR
WELL STIMULATION THOUGH STILL
AVERAGE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
TWELVE PERMITS A YEAR AGAIN
PRODUCING OIL UNDER THE
STRICTEST ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. EVER IN THE IN THE
WORLD I WOULD THINK AND AGAIN I
WOULD JUST CHALLENGE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT WHERE OUR OIL COMES
FROM WHEN WE DON'T PRODUCE IT
HERE CREATE JOBS HERE AND KEEP
THAT HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. OF MANY THAT WE EXPORT
TO THESE OTHER COUNTRIES I
WOULD CHALLENGE YOU GUYS TO
DEFINITELY THINK ABOUT WHERE
OIL IS PRODUCED BECAUSE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE NOT REDUCE
THE CONSUMPTION OF OIL IN ANY
WAY SHAPE OR FORM SO I WOULD
URGE YOU TO VOTE NOW. SENATOR
BURGESS. OH SORRY AND I'M SORRY
AT CENTER MORE LOCKED. I CAN'T
SEE THOSE LITTLE MITES ACUTE
MADAM PRESIDENT IT'S NICE TO BE
CONFUSED WITH THE SENATOR FROM
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA IT'S AN
HONOR. THE SENATOR FROM. KERN
COUNTY JUST LAID IT ALL OUT AND
SO THE QUESTION I WOULD HAVE
AND I'M GLAD YOU HAVE THE
SENATOR FROM MONTEREY ON THIS
BILL BUT- I I'M WONDERING IF
IT'S TIME FOR THIS STATE TO
LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE AS IT
AS IT RELATES TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. THE AMOUNT OF CARBON
FOOTPRINT THAT'S PUT OUT. BY
SHIPPING THE AMOUNT OF OIL. TO
THIS STATE. IS IT'S GOT TO BE A
LOT MORE. THAN IF WE WERE TO
PRODUCE INTERNALLY. AND MAYBE
WE WOULD WE DO A MUCH BETTER
JOB OF KEEPING. THE EMISSIONS
AND ALL THE RELATED AIR QUALITY
CONCERNS WE DO A BETTER JOB
HERE BUT YET WE ARE
CONSTRICTING OURSELVES AND
WE'RE SHIPPING IT FROM PLACES
THAT DON'T DO A VERY GOOD JOB.
SO IT SEEMS A LITTLE
HYPOCRITICAL TIMES THAT WE
WOULD. HAVE SUCH AN AMAZING
IMPACT ON THE ENVIRONMENT IN
THE COUNTRIES THAT. THE SENATOR
FROM. BAKERSFIELD JUST ALLUDED
TO AND WHAT WE COULD DO IT
BETTER AND FROM A NATIONAL
DEFENSE STANDPOINT. WOULDN'T IT
BE BETTER IF WE HAD A GOOD. OIL
PRODUCING. INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THAT WE WEREN'T IMPORTING SO
MUCH IN CASE OF AN EMERGENCY
BECAUSE MOST OF THE FLIGHT.
PLANES CHAPTER WILL WE STILL
NEED ALL THESE OIL PRODUCTS SO
I'M I'M JUST WOULD LOVE TO GET
YOUR PROP PROFESSORIAL
PERSPECTIVE ON MAYBE WE NEED TO
RE EVALUATE WHAT WE'RE DOING
THANK YOU. CENTER MARK THAT IS
A QUESTION AND IF CENTER MONEY
IS WILLING TO ENTERTAIN THAT
QUESTION THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND THROUGH THE CHAIR
GLAD TO RESPOND. SO LET'S NOT
CONFUSE WHAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO
DO THIS BILL DOES NOT SEEK TO
STOP OIL PRODUCTION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT
A COUNTY THAT HAS A LOT OF OIL
PRODUCTION IN SOUTHERN MONTEREY
COUNTY. NORTHERN SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY LET'S LOOK AT
WHAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO IT
REALLY BUILDS ON THE HISTORY OF
SUPERVISORS THE THORNY AT AN
OIL FIELD. STARTING IN NINETEEN
FIFTEEN WHEN WE FIRST ESTABLISH
SUPERVISOR OF THORNY AT ANY OIL
DRILLING OPERATION THEN IN
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE WE AMENDED
THAT TO INCLUDE IN THAT
SUPERVISORS OF FORTY THE
PROTECTION OF GROUND WATER. AS
PART OF THAT RESPONSIBILITY
THAT EVOLVED. TO NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE FOR THE PRUDENT OPERATOR.
AMENDMENTS THAT SET OUT CERTAIN.
PRUDENT OPERATOR REQUIREMENTS
FOR SUPERVISORS SO WE'VE GONE
FROM NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
NINETEEN FIFTEEN NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE. NINETEEN SIXTY ONE.
NOT PUTTING A DENT IN
CALIFORNIA OIL PRODUCTION BUT
INCREASING SAFETY WHAT WE SEEK
TO DO HERE. THROUGH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE SPILL. IS
TO INCLUDE. A PROACTIVE
CONTINGENT OF PRIORITIZING
HUMAN HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AS PART OF THAT
CHECKLIST I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US WHO REPRESENT CONSTITUENTS
WHO LIVE NEAR AROUND OR WORK IN
THE OIL FIELDS WOULD SAY THAT
AS CALIFORNIAN LEGISLATURE WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE AS A PRIORITY
PROTECTING HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT SO ALL THIS DOES IS
SAY AS PART OF THIS EVOLVING
SUPERVISOR A THORNY. LET'S PUT
A PRIORITY ON HUMAN HEALTH
PUBLIC HEALTH AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT. AS ONE OF THOSE
ITEMS ON THE CHECKLIST DOES NOT
STOP OIL PRODUCTION DOES NOT
DISCOURAGE OIL PRODUCTION IT
PUTS CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH
OTHER STATES THAT ARE MINING
OIL AS PUTTING HUMAN HEALTH AND
HUMAN SAFETY AT THE TOP OF THE
LIST. I DON'T THINK ANYONE
WOULD DISAGREE WITH THAT AS A
PRIORITY IN FACT WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH DOCTOR. IS MAKING IT
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
PRODUCTION REQUIREMENTS IN
OTHER INDUSTRIES THAT ALREADY
PRIORITIZE HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT THIS IS CATCHING
DAGR UP TO WHAT WE'RE ALREADY
DOING WITH OTHER PRODUCTION
MECHANISMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CENTER STERN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT DON'T WANT
TO BELABOR THIS DEBATE TOO MUCH
AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
AUTHOR THE JOCKEY AND EVERYONE
AS SENSITIVITIES AND CONCERNS
ABOUT OIL PRODUCTION NEAR THEIR
OWN TOWN OR GAS PRODUCTION NEAR
THEIR HOMETOWN OR PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO MAKE THE TRANSITION
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS. THIS
BILL IS A PRETTY TECHNICAL AND
MODEST MEASURE THERE WILL BE
TIME I THINK FOR A BROADER
DEBATE ABOUT THE FUTURE OF OIL
AND GAS POLICY AND HOW WE SORT
OF SQUARE THAT WITH OUR LIVES
ENERGY DEPENDENCE QUESTIONS
GLOBAL MARKETS HEALTH AND
SAFETY ARE THE BILL WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED THOUGH.
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
RIGHT NOW SO I THINK WE IS A
GOOD PREVIEW OF AN IMPORTANT
FUTURE DEBATE BUT I WOULD JUST
ADMIT THAT I DON'T THINK THAT
THIS VEHICLE IS THE PLACE FOR
THAT I THINK IT'S A IT'S MORE
OF A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP FOR
DOGGER AND LORD KNOWS THEY NEED
IT WHETHER YOU'RE IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY OR IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY DOGGER
NEEDS TO GET ITS ACT TOGETHER
AND HOPEFULLY THIS WILL GIVEN
SOME TOOL TO DO THAT SO. JUST
WANTED TO PUT THAT PLUG IN AND
RESERVE SOME OF THESE IMPORTANT
TOPICS MAYBE FOR A VENUE THAT
HAS A. MORE MEAT TO. SO I
RESPECT ESCRIBIR. SENATOR
BRIDGES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THE JOCKEY A ON THIS
BILL USED A PHRASE EVOLVING
SUPERVISOR AUTHORITY.
IMMEDIATELY REFLEXIVELY BACK.
CHRIS MY CREATE SOME CONCERN MY
ANTENNAE GO UP WHEN I WHEN I
HEAR ABOUT INVOLVING AUTHORITY
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT WE HAVE
HERE IS A SERIES OF WHAT
APPEARED TO BE BEEN NINE
EVOLUTIONS IN WORKPLACE
PROTECTION BUT IN THE TOTALITY
OF CIRCUMSTANCES YOU HAVE A
DEPRESSION IN THE MARKETPLACE
ITSELF ANNA WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
MADE EARLIER I THINK IN ITS IT
WITH THE TOTALITY OF SO WITHIN
A TO TELL THE OF CIRCUMSTANCES
WE'RE LOOKING AT AN INDUSTRY.
THAT IS BEING PENALIZED.
ANNUALLY IN EVERY SINGLE
RESPECT. BUT IT MAKES NO SENSE
IN IN MY MIND GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE THE SOME OF THE BEST
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS WITHIN
THE INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY ACROSS THE GLOBE BUT
YET WE STILL BRING IN THE
FOSSIL FUELS NEEDED TO MAINTAIN
OUR ECONOMY AND OUR WAY OF
LIFE. SORE PENALIZING THE FEW
INDUSTRY PLAYERS THAT REMAINING
CALIFORNIA AND ARE EXPORTING
WHAT I THINK IS A IS A LARGER
IS A LARGER AGENDA TO GET AWAY
FROM THAT BUT REALITY IS WE'RE
NOT READY TO COMPLETELY GET
AWAY FROM IT WE'RE MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION NO DOUBT BUT IT
WON'T BE ELIMINATED. SO I GUESS
MY CONCERN IS THAT WHEN WE GO
AHEAD AND CONTINUE TO ADD MORE
BURDENSOME REGULATIONS INTO AN
ON ON TO AN INDUSTRY IT REALLY
IS FOR. IT REALLY IS. TO HURT
US LONG TERM AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
AND FOR THOSE THAT THAT BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS JUST A BIT NINE.
DISCUSSION POINT OR ITS
DISCREET IN ITS APPLICATION.
TROUBLED APPRECIATED IN THE
LARGER CONTEXT IT'S NOT IT'S
KILLING IN INDUSTRY ON WHICH WE
RELY ECONOMICALLY END FOR
OVERALL QUALITY OF LIFE. I
WOULD CERTAINLY CERTAINLY
SUPPORT A NO VOTE. CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN
AND YOU CAN CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN. THAT
SOME MEMBERS OF THE SENATE HAVE
WHEN THEY SEE BILLS LIKE THIS
BECAUSE OF MAKE NO MISTAKE
ABOUT IT THERE ARE SOME MEMBERS
OF THIS LEGISLATURE THIS SEED
OIL AS THE ENEMY. TO OUR STATE
AND TO OUR COUNTRY AND TO
CLIMATE CHANGE. AND YOU KNOW IF
WE COULD CHANGE FROM. OIL COM
THE CONSUMPTION TO ALTERNATIVE
FORMS OF ENERGY IN THE NEXT
THREE OR FOUR YEARS OR THE NEXT
TWELVE AS SOME DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES CLAIM
THAT WE CAN DO WE COULD BE
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION BUT- YOU
KNOW FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OUR
HISTORY. WE ARE AN OIL EXPORTER.
WE'RE NOT A NET OIL IMPORTER MY
FRIENDS WE NEED SOME
COMPETITION. BECAUSE WE HAVE
MANY MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY MIND THAT ARE BLUE
COLLAR WORKERS THAT HAVE TO BUY
GAS TO GET TO AND FROM THEIR
WORKPLACES SOME OF YOU LIVE IN
COASTAL COMMUNITIES WERE.
GASOLINE PRICES ARE NOT A BIG
ISSUE. THE GASOLINE PRICES ARE
BIG ISSUE. IN MY COMMUNITY
WHERE I HAVE BLUE COLLAR
WORKERS A SOMETIMES DRIVE OVER
A HUNDRED FIFTY MILES ROUND
TRIP TO GO TO WORK. I SEE YOUR
CITIZENS HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
BUYING GASOLINE BUYING FOOD TO
BUY MEDICINE. SO THE
COMPETITION THAT WE HAVE IS
BEING A NET OIL EXPORTER. AND
UTILIZING THE NATURAL RESOURCE
OF NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT THE
UNITED STATES. HAS BEEN A VERY
POSITIVE THING IT'S VERY
UPSETTING TO ME WHEN I SEE
FRIENDS AGO TO. STATES LIKE
TENNESSEE. IN THE PAST COUPLE
WEEKS AND TAKE PICTURES OF THE
COST OF GASOLINE TO TWO DOLLARS
AND TWENTY FIVE CENTS A GALLON.
AND WHERE ARE WE- WE'RE STILL
IN THE FORMS CLOSER TO FIVE
DOLLARS A GALLON DEPENDING ON
THE TIME OF YEAR THAT YOU.
CHECK ON ON THE PRICE OF
GASOLINE. WERE PRICE IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS OUT OF BUSINESS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WHILE THIS IS JUST ADDING MORE.
REGULATIONS THE MORE
REGULATIONS THAT YOU ADD ON AN
INDUSTRY. ON THE MORE ONEROUS
IT IS AND MORE EXPENSIVE IT IS
FOR THEM TO EXIST. NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA BY THE UNITED STATES
AND THESE BUSINESS AS WELL.
FIND THE PATH TO PEACE
RESISTANCE TO WHERE THEY CAN
MAKE A PROFIT. AND AT THE SAME
TIME IT HERE TO. HIGHLY
PROGRESSIVE. AN APPROPRIATE
HEALTH AND SAFETY REGULATIONS
ALLOWING AN INDUSTRY TO. FIVE
AS BEST WE CAN MY COLLEAGUES TO
MADE A VERY CLEAR POINT THE
BRING OIL IN. FROM COUNTRIES
THAT HATE OUR GUTS. COUNTRIES
SAID IF YOU'RE LGBT WILL
SENTENCE YOU TO DEATH OR TO
PRISON. PUTS US AT MORE RISK OF
HAVING DISASTROUS. OIL SPILLS.
ON OUR BEAUTIFUL CLOSE IN OUR
BEAUTIFUL BABIES. BOB WE NEED
TO LOOK AT EVERYTHING A
TOTALITY AND WHILE I UNDERSTAND
AND APPRECIATE MY FRIEND SAYING
THIS IS THE INVOLVING
REGULATORY SCHEME IT IS NOT
RELATIVE TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR RESIDENTS AS IT.
PERTAINS TO THE IMPORTATION OF
THE SAME. AND SO WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS GLOBALLY WE NEED
LOOK AT THIS COMPREHENSIVELY.
AND BASED ON THE REGULATIONS
THAT ARE BEING REPORTED IT'S
PUTTING OUR. PETROLEUM
INDUSTRIES AT A SIGNIFICANT
DISADVANTAGE THAT ARE ALREADY
DEALING WITH SOME OF THE
STRONGER SAFETY REGULATIONS
KNOWN TO THE PLANET. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS LET'S KIND OF
PROTECT THOSE INDUSTRIES THAT
ARE FOLLOWING THE RULES THEY'RE
MAKING US MORE ENERGY
INDEPENDENT THAT ARE PROVIDING
HOPEFULLY. BOB THE VOLUME OF.
PETROLEUM THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
REALLY COMPETE TO PROVIDE A
LOWER COST ENERGY SOURCE FOR
MANY OF OUR RESIDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIRD OF
WHOM. LIVE CLOSE OR NEAR THE
POVERTY LINE BUT HAVING TROUBLE
MAKING ENDS MEET MONTH TO
MONTH. FOR THOSE REASONS LET'S
NOT ADD MORE BURDENS TO THEM.
LET'S NOT NOTE ANY BE FOURTEEN
FORTY. SIGNAL FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
MINING YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK
YOU WELL I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS. CLEARLY THIS BILL HAS
TOUCHED A NERVE. I WOULD SUBMIT
ITS TOUCHED THE WRONG NERVE.
THIS BILL. DOES NOT. GO AGAINST
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA I FIND
IT INTERESTING THAT MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD DRAW A LINE.
BETWEEN THE PROTECTION. OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS HAVE DOCTOR
PRIORITIZE. PUBLIC HEALTH.
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY. AND
TO HAVE A SUPERVISOR IN THE
PERMITTING PROCESS. MAKE SURE
THAT THAT BOX IS CHECKED. TO
ARGUE THAT WE SHOULD NOT IN
FORCE. PUBLIC HEALTH WORKER
SAFETY OR ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AS A PRIORITY OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I THINK
ABANDONED SIR CONSTITUENTS WHO
DEPEND UPON US. TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND SAFETY I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. NOBEL BY BURGESS NO
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG NO
DALY NO DOT. I DORADO I
GALGIANI GLAZER I GONZALEZ HI
GROVE NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO AYE TITLE I JACKSON I
JONES. NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK NO MORALE NO NELSON. NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH.
RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NO NUMBER BYE BYE CASKEY
I WINNER. BY WILK NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BRADFORD BY. GALGIANI ROTH.
HIGHS TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE OH
EIGHT SENATOR BELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AN ACT
RULING HOUSING. REBEL THE FLOOR
IS YOURS PRESIDENT THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DENSITY BONUSES FOR THOSE A
100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS THIS BILL WOULD MAKE A
100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT
ELIGIBLE FOR AN 80% DENSITY
BONUS ABOVE EXISTING ZONE
DENSITY PLUS FOR INCENTIVES OR
CONCESSIONS ADDITIONALLY
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITY BENEFITS
OF LOCATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
NEXT TO TRANSIT THIS BILL MAKES
A HUNDRED PERCENT. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS NEAR
TRANSIT ELIGIBLE FOR UNLIMITED
DENSITY BONUS PLUS THE INCREASE
IN HEIGHT UP TO A LIMIT ARJUN
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SINGMAN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES NOBEL I PORGES
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD HI THERE ALSO
I GALGIANI. I GLAZER NO
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
HILL HI HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. BY
DATO. NO JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING. MORE LOCK HI
MORRELL. NIELSEN NO PAN. I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. STONE. NO
NUMBER OUR CASSIE I WINNER BY
WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURGESS NO. DALY I
DIDN'T KNOW. BRADFORD I GROWTH
NO MONNING. BY MORALE NO STERN.
THE END OF THE ICE TWENTY EIGHT
NOS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE TEN SENATOR
MCGUIRE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
AND ACT REALLY INTO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
PRESIDENT HONOR TO BE AT A
PRISON ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY FIVE
AND BEHALF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA FORTY FIVE EXPANDS ON
CURRENT LAW TO INFORM THE
PUBLIC WITH MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION BEFORE LOCAL
DISTRICTS. APPROVED TAXPAYER
FUNDED SUBSIDIES FOR WAREHOUSE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS A. B.
FORTY FIVE WILL HOLD COMPANIES
TO PROMISES MADE WHEN THEY'RE
ASKING FOR SUBSIDIES AND THEN
MEANS TAKING IN COMMITTEE EVERY
MOVE OPPOSITION FROM CALTRAIN
PER CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. AND THE FOR THE
CITY. OF FRESNO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY THE ROLE PLEASE ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES NOBEL I PORGES NO
BRADFORD. HI KELLY ERA I TING
NO DALY NO DODD HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. I HILL
AYE HUESO AYE HER TITLE I
JACKSON AYE JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. HI
MONNING. HI MORE LOCK NO MORALE
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. BY STERN BY STONE
NOVEMBER. OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK. NO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GLAZER HI. NO IT
WAS ELEVEN. ICE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM THREE ELEVEN
SENATOR LEYVA MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT. CENTER LEYVA.
AT A PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTEEN
WHICH WOULD IMPLEMENT THE STATE
AUDITOR RECOMMENDATIONS BY
ESTABLISHING A TWO YEAR
PROBATION FROM SERVING AS A
GRANT EVALUATOR FOR ANYONE WHO
HAS SERVED AS A REPRESENTATIVE.
VOTING MEMBER OR FORMER STAFF
OF ANY ORGANIZATION OR PERSON
THAT IS APPLYING TO RECEIVE
GRANT FUNDING FROM THE STATE
AGENCY. IN ITS STUDY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND THE TO
PUT THAT THE DEPARTMENT DID NOT
ALWYS FOLLOW THE RULES SET
FORTH IN THEIR OWN GRANT
SOLICITATION MANUAL AND DID NOT
MAKE SURE THAT PERSPECTIVE
EVALUATORS WERE FREE FROM
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST OR BIAS
BEFORE SELECTING THEM. THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO STATUTORY
PROBATION PROHIBITION ON STATE
AGENCIES HIRING GRANT
EVALUATORS THAT PRESENT A
DIRECT CONFLICT OF INTEREST
THROUGH THEIR AFFILIATIONS WITH
THE ORGANIZATION OR PERSONS
APPLYING FOR GRANTS. WHICH
COMPROMISES THE ABILITY OF
CALIFORNIANS TO TRUST THEIR
GOVERNMENT HAS FAIR PROCESSES
IN PLACE THAT WILL TREAT
EVERYONE EQUALLY AB TEN
THIRTEEN WILL HELP TO ENSURE
THAT THE GRANT PROCESS THAT
EVERY STATE AGENCY IS FAIR AND
FREE BIAS THIS LEGISLATION IS
RECEIVED NO NO. VOTE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE RIVER UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL VOTE. SEEING NINE EYES
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
THREE TWELVE. SENATOR DODD
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS ENACT
RULING THE MILK IN MAKING
PROVISION THEREFORE SENATOR
DODD THE FLOOR IS YOURS BETTER
PRESENT MEMBERS AB FIVE NINETY
MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
CURRENT STATE LAW TO COMPLY
WITH CALIFORNIA'S FEDERAL MILK
MARKETING ORDER. HEARING IT HAS
A SUPPORT SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR RIVAL. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
VOTE ON IT ON THE BILL. SEEING
NONE. I IS FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE SIXTEEN.
SENATOR SKINNER. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AN
ACTOR LINDA TRANSPORTATION.
ENTER SKINNER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU I'M MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS THIS
COMES BACK FIVE AND WITH FOR
CONCURRENCE AND IT. RECENT
AMENDMENTS CAN VYING THE INTENT
TO THE BILL TO REDUCING TRAVEL
TIMES THE NUMBER OF STOPS IN
FUEL YOU THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
IT IS UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND IT
AUTHORIZES CITIES WITHIN THE
BAY AREA'S METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION. COMMISSION TO
DEVELOP PLANS FOR TRAFFIC
SIGNAL OPTIMIZATION WITH THAT I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION DARI IS KNOCKING
CURRENTS. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU BOB. SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NINE EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM.
NUMBER THREE TWENTY SENATOR
JACKSON'S. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN OH NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN AND ACT
REALLY INTO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTER JACKSON THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB THIRTEEN OH NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REBEKAH BY OUR
QUE HAN WHICH WOULD PRESERVE
OUR STATE NINETY DAY OPEN
ENROLLMENT PERIOD FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL INSURANCE MARKET AND
SHIFT THE OPEN ENROLLMENT
MARKET A DEADLINE FROM JANUARY
FIFTEENTH. FIFTEENTH TO JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST GIVING
CALIFORNIANS A FEW EXTRA WEEKS
TO SIGN UP FOR COVERAGE WHEN
THE NEW YEAR BEGINS YOU MIGHT
AS WELL WHY ARE WE DOING THIS
THE COUPLE EXTRA WEEKS WELL
THERE'S NEW EVIDENCE THAT SHOWS
THAT PEOPLE WHO SIGN UP
ACTUALLY IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS
OF ANUARY TEND TO BE HEALTHIER
THAN THOSE WHO SIGN UP EARLIER
WHICH WOULD HELP TO STABILIZE
THE INSURANCE MARKET AS A WHOLE
WHY YOU MIGHT ASK WELL THINK
ABOUT IT IF YOU HAVE CHILDREN.
I YOU KNOW THAT THEY TEND TO
WAIT TO THE LAST MINUTE TO DO
ANYTHING I AND THAT IS THE CASE
HERE PEOPLE WHO ARE YOUNGER AND
HEALTHIER TEND TO WAIT UNTIL
THE CLOSING IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE AND OF COURSE WHEN
THIS POOL IS COMPRISED OF BOTH
THE HEALTHIER AS WELL AS THE
NOT HEALTHIER IT BALANCES OUT
THE MARKET AND MAKES IT A MORE
EFFECTIVE FOR EVERYONE IT IS
YOU WILL CONTINUE WITH YOUR
HELP TO CONTINUE THE SUCCESS
OUR STATE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. AND IF
IT'S THE NEARLY TO HELP MILLION
CONSUMERS WHO PURCHASE THEIR
INSURANCE THROUGH COVER
CALIFORNIA AND FROM CONTROL
INSURANCE MARKETS FINALLY
REACHED AMENDMENTS CAN BE ALL
REMOVED ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THIRTY DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ITEM. BUT AT THE VERY
LAST MINUTE THE WORLD IS COMING
TO AN END AND THEY HAVE FAILED
TO SIGN UP FOR SOMETHING THAT
THEY DESPERATELY NEED TO TAKE
CARE OF WHETHER IT BE A HEALTH
CARE ISSUE. A DRIVER'S LICENSE
ISSUE A BABYSITTING STRUCTURE
ISSUE WHATEVER THE ISSUE IS SO
I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM AND THINK THE
EXTENSION IS A GOOD THING SO
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FOR THE PRESENTATION. YET IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE. HAD I BEEN
HAPPY TO MAKE A CLOSE BECAUSE
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS
WHERE WE TRY TO SAVOR THEM BUT
I THINK WHEN WE HAVE CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN WE UNDERSTAND
THIS ISSUE WELL AND WITH THAT I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD DISAGREE.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY AS
FREE I'VE- YOUR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
HI BILL FIVE LARGEST AYE
BRADFORD. I COUNTY AT ALL I
CHIANG I DALY AYE DODD. HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW BY
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO HI
TITLE. I JACKSON I JONES I
LEYVA. MCGUIRE. BY MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE MOORLACH AYE
AMARILLO. NELSON HI. PAN AND.
PAN BY MORRELL AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG OUR
CASSIE AYE WIENER AYE WILK BY.
JACKSON MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE TWENTY ONE.
SENATOR RUBIO. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AN ACT RELATING TO
PEOPLE IN SOON HEALTH CENTER
RUBIO THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENTE MEMBERS
SHARE PRICE TO PRESENT AB SIX
TWENTY FOUR THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE SCHOOLS THAT CHOOSE TO
ISSUE STUDENT ID CARDS TO
INCLUDE PHONE NUMBERS FOR
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH MEANS I NEED AT THE
SCHOOL ID. THE PURPOSE OF THIS
LEGISLATION. THE PURPOSE OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS TO ENSURE
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
THOSE FACING A CHALLENGING
SITUATION INVOLVING SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR SEXUAL HEALTH ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS TIMELY AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION. ESSENTIAL
TO THE PHYSICAL AND MENTAL WELL
BEING OF THE STUDENT
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A REAL
AN URGENT NEED FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION. STATISTICS
DEMONSTRATE THE ONE IN THE
GIRLS WILL EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR ABUSE BY THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN AND SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS RATES
CONTINUE TO RISE AMONG YOU
THINK CALIFORNIA. EIGHTY SIX
TWENTY FOUR WOULD MAKE THE
TEMPTATION MARK EAST BAY
ACCESSIBLE ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE.
USER EDGE MAYBE. I'M SORRY
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE INTERNET
USAGE MAY BE MONITORED BY THEIR
ABUSER. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR APPLE THANK YOU. FOR
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES NO BELL. WE'RE JUST
NO BRADFORD I CAN BE AT ALL I
CHIANG. NO. DALY NO DODD. HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TITLE AYE JACKSON AYE JONES.
NO LEYVA MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING AYE MOORLACH NUMBER
RAIL NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE NO
I'M BURKE OUR COUNTY I WINNER
BY WILK NO. YOU MOVE THE CALL
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
TWENTY TWO. SENATOR HER TITLE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SEVENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AN ACT RELATING TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION CENTER HER
TAUGHT OF THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO TODAY
TO PRESENT AB TWELVE SEVENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GAVE A
WHICH WILL REQUIRE THE CAMPUSES
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY I REQUEST THE
CAMPUSES OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO INCLUDE ON THE
INTERNET WEBSITE BASED STUDENT
ACCOUNTS OR STUDENT PORTALS AT
THE INSTITUTION NOTICE OF
CALPERS AND LOCAL OR COUNTY
LEVEL HOUSING AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. AB EIGHT TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT WOULD STREAMLINED
THE PROCESS FOR STUDENTS TO
EASILY GAIN ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES IN A DISCREET
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE MANNER.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
BOAT. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. EIGHT I BILL BY PORGES.
BRADFORD HI. ZERO HI I CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD BY THE
RUSSELL AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ BY GROVE I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I
TOTAL AYE JACKSON AYE JONES I
LEYVA. MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
MITCHELL HI MONNING. I'M MORE
LUCK I'M A REAL. AYE NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE. HI NUMBER. HI WHY
BECAUSE HE BY WIENER AYE WILK
BY. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
BURGESS HI LEYVA HI. PRICE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING I DON'T ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE TWENTY THREE
SENATOR DR SO. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
IMPLEMENT SENATOR OUT DORADO
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AB ONE SEVENTY
BILLS ON THE PROTECTIONS
AFFORDED IN THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ACT AND ENSURES
THAT CONTRACTED WORKERS CAN
HOLD BOTH THEIR EMPLOYER AND
CONTRACTING EMPLOYER LIABLE FOR
HARASSMENT IN THE ORKPLACE
THIS BILL SEEKS TO PROTECT ARE
VULNERABLE. LOW WAGE WORKERS
WERE OFTEN WOMEN WOMEN OF COLOR
IMMIGRANTS AND THOSE WERE MOST
IN NEED OF PROTECTION FROM
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE THE
TREND WE HAVE SEEN ESPECIALLY
IN SOME INDUSTRIES LIKE
JANITORIAL AND HOTEL SERVICES
HAS BEEN TOWARDS OUTSOURCING
WORK TO STAFFING AGENCIES. THE
SUBCONTRACTOR WORKERS GO TO
WORK EACH DAY THE SAME LOCATION
WEARING MANY TIMES THE UNIFORM
OF THE OFFICE OR HOTEL THEIR
CLEANING AND REPORTING TO
SUPERVISORS ON SITE HOWEVER
THESE CONTRACTING COMPANIES AND
HOTELS ARE NOT HELD RESPONSIBLE
ONE SEXUAL HARASSMENT HAPPENS.
ON THEIR WATCH TO THEIR WORK.
THE RESULT OF A LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY HAVE BEEN HORROR
STORIES OF ABUSES IN THE
WORKPLACE. PERPETRATED BY THE
SAME ACTORS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. EMPLOYERS SHOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO DODGE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY OF ENSURING A
SAFE WORKPLACE. SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY OUTSOURCE WORK TO
CONTRACTING COMPANIES THIS BILL
IS INSPIRED BY THE STORY OF
SOUND UP THIS GATHER. A HOTEL
WORKER WHO BRAVELY CAME FORWARD
TO TELL HER STORY OF BEING
SEXUALLY HARASSED BY THE
CONTRACTOR ON THE JOB. B ONE
SEVENTY WOULD ENSURE THAT
SUBCONTRACTED WORKERS LIKE
SANDRA CAN SEEK RECOURSE FROM
BOTH THE DIRECT EMPLOYER AND
CONTRACTED EMPLOYER. IF THEY
HAVE EXPERIENCED ANY FORM OF
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE.
EMPLOYERS TO BE LIABLE FOR THE
ACTS OF THEIR CONTRACTED
SUPERVISORS. EMPLOYERS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CONDUCT AND
WELL BEING OF ALL OF THE
WORKERS THAT ARE BROUGHT INTO
THEIR WORKPLACE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SENATOR
MOORLACH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I JUST HELLO
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL BECAUSE WE DO OUR BEST TO
TRY TO DETERMINE THAT THOSE WE
EITHER HIGHER OR THOSE THAT WE
CONTRACT WITH HAVE DONE. THE
PROPER VETTING IMPROPER. REVIEW
OF THOSE THAT WILL BE IN
SUPERMAJORITY POSITIONS BUT
REGRETFULLY PEOPLE LIE. AND YOU
CAN HIRE SOMEONE YOU THINK IS
REALLY A COMPETENT MANAGER
SUPERVISOR WHEN THERE MAY BE A
HIDDEN PAST THAT KIND OF COMES
TO SURPRISE YOU SO I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW FAR THE
BILL GOES I JUST RECENTLY
WHOPPING 70% OF HIRING MANAGERS
HAVE CUT APPLICANTS PUTTING
FABRICATIONS ON THE ROUTE TO
MAYES. IT'S JUST BEING TO BE A
MILLENNIAL THING MAYBE PERHAPS.
BUT TERM. THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
THE ARTICLE SAID SORRY. AND
THAT'S AN ALMOST 20% INCREASE
SINCE THE TWENTY FIFTEEN REPORT
WHEN FIFTY EIGHT SPOTTED ARE
RIGHT EXAGGERATIONS YADA YADA
COLLEAGUES. WE HIRED A MANAGER
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE. THAT HAD
A HISTORY THAT JUST DID NOT.
COME OUT AND ALL THE RESEARCH
THAT WAS DONE IT TURNED OUT TO
BE ONE OF OUR- WORSE HARASSMENT
INCIDENTS EVER. I GUESS THE
MEMBER VOLUNTEERING FOR
NONPROFIT THEIR BOARD WIN
THROUGH A COMPLETE ANALYSIS AND
HIRED AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
TURNED OUT THAT HE WAS ACTUALLY
AN ATTEMPTED MURDER MAY FINALLY
FOUND IN MANY WAS THE EXECUTOR
OF THINGS HAPPEN I JUST I WANT
TO PROTECT PEOPLE THAT ARE
TRYING TO DO THEIR BEST TO RUN
BUSINESSES. AND HAVE THE
JEOPARDY THE RISK OF RETAINING
SOMEONE THAT HAS A HIDDEN PAST
THE DOUBLE LIFE AND MAYBE THIS
BILL JUST GOES A JUST A TAD TOO
FAR BECAUSE WE WANT TO GO AFTER
THE PERPETRATORS. WE WANT TO
TAKE CARE OF. THE ISSUE BECAUSE
WE DON'T WANNA LOSE A TEAM
MEMBER BY A BAD SUPERVISOR BUT
WE'VE ALSO GOT TO BE CAREFUL
HOW HOW HARD THE HAMMER HITS.
AND WITH THAT I HAVE SOME
RESERVATIONS ABOUT THIS BILL
LOOK FORWARD TO THE- FLOOR
MANAGER PROVIDING MAYBE A
LITTLE MORE INFORMATION TO MAKE
ME FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. SENATE
PURCHASE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I TO SHARE SOME
CONCERNS I THINK. OF THE AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL. OZ HEART IN THERE
IS IN THE RIGHT PLACE WE'VE
SEEN. WE SEE WORKPLACE
HARASSMENT AND WE'VE SEEN IT IN
WITH CONTRACTORS IN CONTRACT
DIS. SO WE KNOW IT EXISTS. BUT
THERE'S ALSO A PRINCIPLE IN LAW.
AND IT IS KNOWN OR SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN. AND IN THE CONTEXT OF AN
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIP
OR WITH CONTRACT DIS. I BELIEVE
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PROPER
VETTING IF THERE'S AN EMPLOYER
OR A CONTRACTOR DEALING WITH
CONTRACT THESE TO DO THERE ARE
TO DO THEIR BEST TO DEVELOP
THOSE CANDIDATES. AND IN A
SCENARIO THAT THAT THAT THE NEW
OR SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THIS
INDIVIDUAL POSED A RISK. BUT I
THINK THIS MIGHT BE GOING IN.
IN UNINTENDED DIRECTION AS WELL
IS THAT WE COULD BE
DISCOURAGING. BUSINESSES FROM
HIRING CONTRACTORS IN WORKING
WITH CONTRACT DIS. EVERYTHING
EVERYTHING IS BEING BROUGHT IN
HOUSE I THINK WITH THIS
LEGISLATION IT'S DISCOURAGING
EMPLOYERS FROM REACHING OUT
INTO INTO THE COMMUNITY AND IN
HIRING FOLKS THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY IN IN THE HOUSE OR
IN THE SHOP IN SO I THINK THIS
HAS BEEN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
BUT I THINK DERAILS IT I WOULD
I WOULD CAUTION MY COLLEAGUES
THAT THIS MAY SOUND ODD AS IF
IT IS PURSUING JUSTICE IN
MAKING CERTAIN THE INDIVIDUALS
ARE SAFE IN THE WORKPLACE. BUT
THE INDICATE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES COULD VERY WELL
CHANGE HOW WE DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE I WOULD I
WOULD URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
CAST A NO VOTE IN ITS CURRENT
FORM. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. AT CENTER
STONE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I'VE
BEEN A. MICROPHONE DON'T WANT
TO STAND UP. I HAVE BEEN A I
THINK A RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYER
NOW FOR THE PAST THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS. AND WE'VE GOT OUR
EMPLOYEES AS BEST WE CAN TO
ENSURE THAT. WE'RE HIRING
HONORABLE PEOPLE THAT RESPECT
THE RIGHTS OF MEN AND WOMEN IN
OUR RANKS AND. BILL VERY
FORTUNATE THAT IN THE PAST
THIRTY SEVEN YEARS THAT WE HAVE
NEVER HAD A CLAIM OF OUR
HARASSMENT LEVIED AGAINST ANY
OF MY BUSINESSES. CAM KNOCKING
ON WOOD WHEN I SAY THAT THANK
YOU. BUT THIS BILL. CAN REALLY
COST SOME MAJOR ISSUES FOR
BUSINESS PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF
THAT DO ALL THEY CAN. WITH THE
LAWS THAT EXIST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND LET ME REMIND
YOU ABOUT THE KIND OF LAWS THAT
WE BEEN. ENTERTAINING HERE IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE. THERE'S
BEEN A MOVEMENT HERE THAT WE
WANT TO GET CRIMINALS.
REHABILITATED AN EMPLOYEE AID.
AND YET WE DON'T WANT THE
EMPLOYERS TO KNOW ABOUT THAT
CRIMINAL HISTORY TO GIVE THESE
PEOPLE A FRESH START IN LIFE
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND IF WE
DON'T DO THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF VETTING THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO NOT HIRE AN INDIVIDUAL BASED
ON THEIR FELONIOUS PAST. THEN
WE'RE GOING TO BASICALLY HOLD
THAT BUSINESS AT A DEEP POCKET
LIABILITY FOR. ISSUES OUTSIDE
THEIR CONTROL. AND THERE
VETTING PROCESSES THERE NEEDS
TO BE SOME CABBIE OUGHT TO THIS
LEGISLATION THAT IF A LEAD IF
AN EMPLOYER GOES THROUGH ALL
THE HOOPS. THAT ARE NECESSARY
AT THE TIME OF A HIGHER TO
ENSURE THAT. THEY'RE HIRING
SOMEBODY THAT DOES NOT POSE A
RISK. TO ANY OF THEIR EMPLOYEES
THAT THEY SHOULD BE EXEMPTED
FROM THE DEEP POCKET LIABILITY
OF. OF THIS BILL. LOOK AT THE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL MY
FRIENDS WERE TALKING ABOUT
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF CHAMBERS
OF COMMERCE AND SEE THIS. AS A
LIGHTNING ROD ISSUE. AS A
POTENTIAL JOB KILLER BILL. WE
NEED TO BE MORE HOSPITABLE TO
EMPLOYERS AT A TIME WHEN MANY
ARE FLEEING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TRY TO RETAIN
THOSE AND FOSTER A BUSINESS
FRIENDLY ENVIRONMENT SO THAT
PEOPLE WILL COME HERE. TO DO
COMMERCE BECAUSE LET ME SAY I
BELIEVE THE DAY OF RECKONING
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
COMING. IT'S COMING BECAUSE I
CALL IT DEATH BY A THOUSAND
SLICES EMPLOYERS ARE NOT GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK IN A
HOSTILE STATE. THAT IS NOT
RESPECTIVE UP THE GOOD WORK
THAT EMPLOYERS TRY TO DO NOT
ONLY TO IMPROVE COMMERCE. FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PROVIDING JOBS AND REVENUE AND
AT THE SAME TIME DOING THE BEST
THEY CAN. BUT WHETHER YOU HAVE
TEN EMPLOYEES ARE TWENTY
EMPLOYEES LIKE MYSELF OR MORE
TO ENSURE THAT THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY'RE HIRING. ARE GOING TO.
RESPONSIBLE SUPERVISORS FOR THE
PEOPLE OVER WHICH THERE
OVERSEEING. LET'S NOT KILL THE
BABY WITH THE BATHWATER LET'S
RECOGNIZE THOSE GOOD LAWYERS TO
TAKE THE EXTRA STEP TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THE PEOPLE THAT THEY
HIRE. ARE RESPONSIBLE JURORS
BUT THAT'S ALSO. I EMPLOYERS
NOT TO HAVE THE FULL ODIOUS
HISTORY OF AN EMPLOYEE A
POTENTIAL EMPLOYEE A POTENTIAL
SUPERVISOR TO SAFEGUARD THE
EMPLOYEES THAT THAT BUSINESS
ALREADY HAS FOR THOSE REASONS.
AND MANY MORE HIGHER TO NOTE
VOTE IN AB ONE SEVEN. IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN CENTER DRAWS
YOU MAKE COULD CONCLUDE. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES OF REAR COMMENTS
THERE IS UNINTENTIONAL
CONSEQUENCE THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR HERE AND THAT IS THAT ALL
MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK IN THAT
WORKPLACE FOR THAT COMPANY.
THAT THEY GET THE SAME RGHTS
AND PROTECTIONS AS THE PEOPLE
THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT THEY'RE
WORKING IN AND AROUND THE- THIS
IS NOT. OUTSOURCING SHOULD NOT
BE AN EXCUSE FOR A DOUBLE
STANDARD A DOUBLE STANDARD WHEN
IT COMES TO THE PROTECTIONS
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE AS MEN
AND WOMEN LET'S DO BUSINESS IN
A WAY THAT POLLS A STANDARD FOR
ALL WORKERS. IT SHOULDN'T BE
ONE OR THE OTHER AND IF YOU
TALK ABOUT HOSTILITY I DON'T%
THINK THERE SHOULD BE HOSTILITY
TO EMPLOYERS BUT I ALSO DON'T
THINK THAT WE SHOULD PROTECT
HOSTILITY TO MEN AND WOMEN WHO
WORK HARD EVERY SINGLE DAY. SO
I REALLY HOPE SYSTEM I'M SORRY.
THE BROTHERS COLLEAGUES OF THAT
WE LOOK AT THIS IN A WAY THAT
IF YOU HAVE A WORKPLACE AT SOME
OF THOSE MEN AND WOMEN THEY'RE
ALL MIXED IN WITH OTHER MEN AND
WOMEN WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
SAME PLACE AND THERE'S THIS
LOOPHOLE OF BEING A CONTRACTED
OUT EMPLOYEE SOMEHOW YOU DON'T
HAVETHE SAME RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS I DON'T THINK ANY
BUSINESS SHOULD FUNCTION THAT
WAY SO THIS IS. MEANT TO NOT
HAVE A DOUBLE STANDARD IN THE
WORKPLACE BUT TO HAVE THE SAME
STANDARD OF RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA ATKINS.
BATES NOBEL I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD. CARRIERA I CHIANG. NO
DALY NO DOT. THE RUSSELL HI
GALGIANI GLAZER. GONZALEZ. BY
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG I HILL.
HUESO BY TITLE. NO. JACKSON BY
JONES. NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
AYE MITCHELL. BY MONNING BY
MORE LUCK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO. BY ROTH.
RUBIO SKINNER. BY STERN BY
STONE NO AMBERG BY CASKEY I
WINNER. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA.
ATKINS BRADFORD. DODD. GALGIANI
NO GLAZER. HILL ROTH. RUBIO
NUMBER. WIENER WIENER AYE.
DRAWS A MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS
ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE TWENTY NINE.
SENATOR US OF. QUESTION ON THE
FLOOR MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US
AN ACT RELATING TO HOMELESSNESS.
SENATOR DORADO. AND. WE'RE ON
ITEM NUMBER THREE TWENTY NINE.
SENATOR DRUG SO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THIS IS WE FIFTY YES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OF AB
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
LOSE BELIEVE US TAKES AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS HELPING
THE HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL FULFILL ITS
GOAL OF ENDING YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE BY
ADDING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AS A
MEMBER. AS SCHOOLS ARE OFTEN
THE FIRST TO IDENTIFY HOMELESS
STUDENTS CD E. IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO SERVE ON THE
COUNCIL IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
CHILD HOMELESSNESS BY ADDING
THE C. D. E. TO THE COUNCIL AB
FIFTY EIGHT WOULD INSURE. THOSE
WHO WORK DIRECTLY WITH HOMELESS
STUDENTS ARE GIVEN A SEAT AT
THE TABLE AMENDMENTS WERE
RECENTLY TAKEN TO ADDRESS
CHAPTER IN OUT ISSUES THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
HAS NO REGISTER OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTE. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SENATE URGING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY AS A CO AUTHOR OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY EIGHT AS WE
WORK TO SOLVE OR STATES
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS CHILDREN
AND YOUNG PEOPLE ARE AT RISK OF
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS
ADDING A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
WE ESTABLISH A STRONG NEXUS
BETWEEN OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND A HOMELESS
PRODUCTION STRATEGY. EVERY
CHILD IN CALIFORNIA IS ENTITLED
TO AN EDUCATION REGARDLESS OF
THEIR SOCIAL ECONOMIC CONDITION
THIS IS ONE OF MANY IMPORTANT
STEPS WE CAN TAKE IN ORDER TO
MAKE A REAL IMPACT ON THE
HOMELESS EPIDEMIC IN OUR STATE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING A.
B. FIFTY. THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS. ITEM SEEING
NONE. I THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
THIRTY SENATOR DR SO THIS IS
THE SENATOR DR SO DAYS SO THAT
WE MIGHT AS WELL JUST KEEP YOUR
MARKET. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
ME THREE THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AN
ACT RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. SENATOR AHEAD SO
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU.
AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO ALLOWS THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY TO ISSUE
ADVANCE PAYMENTS FOR GRANT
RECIPIENTS TO IMPROVE THEIR
ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS A REDUCE
EXPOSURE TO TOXIC CHEMICALS
CURRENTLY MANY NONPROFITS THAT
ARE SELECTED FOR FUNDING.
RESPONSIBLE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
CARRYING THE FULL COST OF
COMPLEMENT COMPLETING A PROJECT
BEFORE THEY CAN BE REIMBURSED
THIS IS TYPICALLY NOT A PROBLEM
FOR LARGER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE RESOURCES BUT FOR SMALLER
NON PROFITS THAT ARE OFTEN CASH
STRAPPED IT CAN BE A LARGE
BARRIER AND DISCOURAGE
APPLICATIONS FOR THE PROGRAM IN
THE FIRST PLACE. THIS MEASURE
HAS SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE YES. I THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE THIRTY THREE.
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AT AND COOKIES ME
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ A
SOME OF THE ONE SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE ENACT
REALLY INTO NEW OTOR VEHICLES
CENTER JONES OF FORAGERS THE
TERM AND MICHAEL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB ONE
SEVENTY NINE WHICH MAKES
CHANGES TO THE FRANCHISE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
NEW CAR DEALERS AND THE
AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURES. NEW
CAR DEALERS OPERATING AS LOCAL
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED FRANCHISE
DEALERS EMPLOY OVER ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER PRIMARY
SOURCE OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
MANY COMMUNITIES THE MOTOR FOR
VEHICLE FRANCHISE Là HAS BEEN
IN CALIFORNIA STATUTE FOR
ALMOST FORTY YEARS AND AS THE
PRIMARY GUIDE GOVERNING THE
INTERACTION BE TO OF MOTOR
VEHICLE DEALERS AND
MANUFACTURERS THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT THE BALANCE OF POWER
BETWEEN THOSE ENTITIES IS
BALANCED WITH ADEQUATE DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS FOR DISPUTES
BETWEEN BOTH PARTIES. THE
pHOURS FACILITATING NEGOTIATIONS
BETWEEN THE SPONSOR AND THE
AUTOMAKERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
AYE VOTE THIS AFTERNOON ON AB
ONE SEVENTY NINE. IS IT ANY
DISCUSSION DEBATE. SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS.
SEEING NONE I THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE THIRTY FIVE. SENATOR HER
TITLE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AN ACT RELATING TO
MIGRANT EDUCATION. SENATOR HER
TAUGHT OF THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REGULAR. A. B. THIRTEEN INTO
WILL PROVIDE THE OPTION TO
MIGRANT STUDENTS TO COMPLETE
THEIR ACADEMICS AT THEIR SCHOOL
OF ORIGINAL ENROLLMENT AND
CONTINUE THE METICULOUS IN
THEIR INTO THEIR ORIGINAL PETER
SCHOOL DESPITE CHANGING
RESIDENTS. BECAUSE EXISTING
SCHOOL DISTRICT POLICIES
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO ENROLL IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT OF THE
RESIDENTS SOME MIGRANT STUDENTS
CHANGE SCHOOLS ALMOST EVERY
YEAR DEPENDING WHERE THEIR
FAMILIES RELOCATE TO FIND WORK.
AB THIRTEEN NINETEEN SIX TO
MINIMIZE SUCH ACADEMIC AND
SOCIAL DISRUPTIONS FOR MIGRANT
STUDENTS BY GIVING THEM THE
OPTION TO REMAIN IN THEIR SAME
SCHOOL DESPITE MOVING. AT THIS
THIS BILL IS CO SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
A BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIA'S TOGETHER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
IT ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
BURGESS. THE QUESTION FOR THE
FLOOR MANAGER. UNDER HER
TERRITORY WILLING TO ACCEPT
QUESTION YES I THINK A WE KNOW
THAT INSTANCES OF MIGRANT
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY IN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS THE DO MOVE
AROUND QUITE A BIT ODD THIS LAW
DOES NOT PERTAIN TO THIS
PROPOSAL DOES NOT PERTAIN TO
ANY OTHER SCENARIO WHERE YOU'D
HAVE A STUDENTS WHO WOULD MOVE
AROUND OR HAVE OCCASION TO MOVE
AROUND AS WELL. BEING ABLE TO
STAY IN ONE SCHOOL. I'M NOT I
DON'T HAVE THE EXACT ANSWER FOR
YOU NOT TO MY UNDERSTANDING BUT
I'D BE HAPPY TO. PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION AND GET MORE
INFORMATION TO YOU. IF THAT'S
HELPFUL. I'LL BE SUPPORTER THIS
IS SPECIALLY GIVEN THE VERY
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE
FIND SPECIAL WITHIN THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY THAT
THIS IS THIS COULD BE QUITE
HELPFUL. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE OF THIS
ALSO IS A CANDIDATE FOR A
UNANIMOUS VOTE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. SAYING NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. THIRTY NINE ICE
ZERO KNOWS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. CENTER ARCHULETA.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
LEGAL SEVEN SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NECESSARY IN AN
ACT REALLY INTO HOMELESSNESS
SENATOR TO LETTER THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. TODAY I'M
PRESENTING A. B. SEVEN SIX ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS ARI AND
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF MILITARY AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE ADJUTANT
GENERAL TO USE ARMORIES AS
HOMELESS SHELTERS THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR WHEN THERE'S HAZARDOUS
CONDITIONS SUCH AS EXTREME
HEAT. IN THE SUMMER AND
EXTREME. IN THE WINTER. AS YOU
ARE WHERE CALIFORNIA IS THE
MIDDLE OF A CRISIS WITH
HOMELESSNESS AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. CALIFORNIA HAD
AN ESTIMATED HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND. PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN DAY
AS REPORTED BY THE CONTINUOUS
OF CARE TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
THIS PRESENTS IMMEDIATE THREATS
TO THE WELL BEING AND SAFETY OF
THOSE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS STATE OWN ARMORIES
HAVE LONG PROVIDED A RESOURCE.
TO COMMUNITY SEEKING SITE FOR
EMERGENCY SHELTER. THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW ARMY DEEMED BACON
BY DEPARTMENT OF MILITARY TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR. THIS BILL INSURERS THERE
IS ANOTHER MEANS AVAILABLE TO
PROTECT INDIVIDUAL LIVING
INDIVIDUALS LIVING ON THE
STREETS AND THIS WOULD BE OUR
PART. WHEN WE SAY YES THE
AMENDMENT HAS BEEN ON THE FLOOR
IN A TECHNICAL NATURE BUT IT IS
PASSED THIS BILL HAD RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES
FOR THIS REGION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE. THIRTY
DISCUSSION HEARD ON THIS ITEM.
CENTER GROVE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I AM RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR BRINGING IT UP
WHAT A COMMON SENSE SOLUTION WE
HAVE SEVERAL ARMORIES AND A
COUPLE OF NATIONAL GUARD
FACILITIES IN OUR COMMUNITY
THERE'D HAVE BERWICK'S THEY
HAVE BEDS THEIR BLANKETS THEY
HAVE A KITCHEN. THEY HAVE
BATHROOMS THEY HAVE SHOWERS WE
NOW HAVE EVERYTHING THAT WE
WOULD NEED TO HOUSE AND MAKE
SURE THE HOMELESS WERE BETTER
TAKING CARE OF THAN BEING ON
THE STREET SO I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR AND BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND FOR YOU
CARRYING THAT BILL SIR. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM
ABOUT. SENATE RECORD. YOU JUST
A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR IT
THERE IS AN THROUGH THE THROUGH
THE CHAIR CENTER OUR CHARGE OF
YOUR THE PENSIONER JUST SIMPLY
BECAUSE WERE I'M DEALING WITH
THE NATION OF AN ARMORY LOCATED
RIGHT IT'S ACTUALLY ON A HIGH
SCHOOL CAMPUS AND IT'S AN ODD
THING WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
TRANSFER THIS. ARMORY OR TO THE
HIGH SCHOOL BRAWLEY. WAS IS
THAT IS A POSSIBLE TO SET UP A
HOMELESS SHELTER RIGHT THERE IN
THE HIGH SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL
GROUNDS WOULD THAT BE A GOOD.
LOCATION WITH THIS OPENNESS.
THAT IS A PROCESS FOR THAT.
SENATOR ARCHULETA YOU MAY
RESPOND. ISSUE THIS IS STATE
OWNED PROPERTY. SO WE WOULD
HAVE TO LOOK IN WITH THE CITY
THE COUNTY IN YOUR PARTICULAR
CASE. BUT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT STATE OWN ARMORIES THIS
IS THE ISSUE HERE BECAUSE AS AS
MY COLLEAGUE IS. THE STATED
THEIR FACILITIES WILL BE ABLE
TO BE USED WITH SHOWERS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE. SO WOULD HAVE
TO LOOK INTO THAT BUT I WOULD
BE A GREAT IDEA PROVIDING THE
CITY THE COUNTY WOULD GO ALONG
WITH. I JUST SIMPLY ASK MAYBE
IF YOU'D BE WILLING TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE MAYBE TO ADD A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL. IN SOME
KIND OF. INTENT LOCATE THESE
FACILITIES ACTUAL ACTUALLY ON
THE GROUNDS I MEAN THE WAY THIS
FACILITY IS SET UP I COULD SHOW
YOU ON THE MAP IT'S RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE SCHOOL AND
IT'S ODD THAT THAT EVER
HAPPENED MAYBE I DON'T KNOW HOW
IT HAPPENED BUT IT'S THERE
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THAT BUT I'M VERY CONCERNED
THAT WE MAY. ADD THIS ELEMENT
TO A HIGH SCHOOL WHERE WHERE IT
DOESN'T BELONG. BETTER BRAINY I
WILL BE HAPPY TO LOOK INTO THAT
AND SEE HOW WE COULD MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS. AND IN BRING THAT
FORWARD. THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING THEN I CENTER TO LEAD I
TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES. YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE THE I. BOLT. THIS IS
AN ITEM THAT. IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS VOTE IF THERE IS
NO OBJECTION. SEEING NO
OBJECTION I. THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE FORTY SIX.
SENATOR LEYVA. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN AN ACT RELATING TO
PEOPLE'S CENTER LEYVA THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY TWO
WOULD REQUIRE TEACHERS TO
PROVIDE MISSED HOMEWORK IF A
PARENT OR GUARDIAN REQUESTS IT
WHEN A STUDENT IS SUSPENDED THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
PREVENT STUDENTS FROM FALLING
BEHIND IN BECOMING MORE OF A
DISCIPLINARY PROBLEM IT IS NOT
THE INTENT OF AB NINETY TWO TO
ADD ADDITIONAL BURDENS FOR
TEACHERS SINCE THE TEACHERS
ALREADY HAVE A PREPARED LESSON
PLAN. THEY WOULD JUST NEED TO
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH THE
PARENT OR GUARDIAN UPON REQUEST
THIS BILL IS JUST OE SMALL
STEP TOWARDS ADDRESSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. NUMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL VOTE.
SEE NO OBJECTION ICE THIRTY
NINE KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. YOU WE WILL MOVE ON NOW
TO ITEM THREE FORTY SEVEN.
SENATOR NIELSEN. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING. CENTER
NIELSEN FLOOR IS YOURS. THIS
BILL IS ANOTHER OF THE MANY
THAT WE'VE DEALT WITH RELATED
TO THE RICH AND PARADISE FIRE.
AND IT'S INTENT IS TO. I DON'T
WANT TO SEE FAST TRACK BUT
PRISCILLA TAPE. A RAPID
APPROVAL. OF THESE PROJECTS. IN
AREAS THAT WERE SO DRASTICALLY
AFFECTED. BY THE CAR FIRE. AND
WE'VE GOTTEN TREMENDOUS SUPPORT.
OUT OF THE COMMUNITIES IN THAT
COUNTY WHO WERE IMPACTED.
PARTICULARLY OR A BILL BRADLEY.
AND YES EVEN CHICO. AND THAT'S
WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THE YEARS.
THE OVERALL PLAN TO
REHABILITATE THE COUNTY. THE
RICH AND THOSE MANY COMMUNITIES
THE DECEMBER BUT GALLAGHER
SEVEN DOLLARS CENTER TO DOLLY
AND I REPRESENT. IS TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A SHORT MEDIUM AND LONG
TERM PLAN. THIS IS A PART OF
THE SHORTER TERM PLAN. TO GET
ACCOMMODATIONS BACK IN ORDER TO
DEAL WITH THE POPULATION. I ASK
AND I WILL. SIR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. CENTER
AYE KOWSKI MEN PRESENT I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
AND I'M NOT I'M I'M KEENLY
AWARE OF THE DISASTER THAT
OCCURRED IN PARADISE BUT TO
SEEK WERE. SEE QUIRK.
LEGISLATION BEFORE HAS DOES
NOTHING FOR THE CITY OF
PARADISE EVERY BUILDING EVERY
HOME EVERY BUSINESS THAT WAS
BURNED OUT IN PARADISE HAS AN
ABSOLUTE. RIGHT TO REBUILD
EXACTLY AS IT WAS THEIR EXAM
WHAT I OBJECT TO IS THIS IS A
FOR COUNTY SEVEN CITY SEQUEL
EXEMPTION SOME OF THE CITIES
ARE FIFTY MILES AWAY FROM. NICE
ORAL IN THIS ON THE FIVE.
SEVERAL OTHER CITIES ALONG THE
FIVE YUBA CITY IS ABOUT FORTY
MILES AWAY I MEAN IF I HAVE AN
EARTHQUAKE IN MY DISTRICT IN
HEY WERE IN FREMONT CALIFORNIA
I'M NOT LOOKING TO BUILD HOUSES
FIFTY MILES AWAY IN SAN
FRANCISCO OR GILROY CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL BEFORE US. ALLOWS FOR
A MINIMUM OF FOUR HOUSES PER
ACRE. THE FOUR HOUSES PER ACRE
IS CLASSIC SUBURBAN SPRAWL IN
THE SEVEN CITIES INTO HAITI
MIND IN M. Q. COUNTY AND IF
YOU'RE NOT ON PRIME FARMLAND.
THEN YOU CAN YOU CAN ACTUALLY
BUILD THE HOUSES IN THESE IN
THESE AREAS THE PRIME FARMLAND
THE LEASING VIEW COUNTY IS ONLY
ABOUT 30% OF THE OF THE OF THE
COUNTY SO THERE'S A DEFINITION
THAT MANY OF US LOOK AT. IN OUR
SYMPATHY TO WANT TO HELP OUT
THE PEOPLE PARADISE WE'RE
LOOKING AT A FOUR COUNTY AREA
AROUND IT. I'M CHALLENGE TO
FIND. TO FIND OUT WHY THIS HAS
TO GO ONE BUT WHAT I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT MANTA PRESIDENT
IS THE PRESIDENT THAT THIS
BILL. SETS BECAUSE OTHER CITIES
AND OTHER COUNTIES ARE GOING TO
BE HERE IF WE HAVE ADISASTER
OTHERS OTHER UNAFFECTED AREAS
YOU KNOW SOMEBODY'S GONNA HAVE
TO BUY SELL TRAVEL FIFTY MILES
FROM ONE OF THESE NEW HOUSES TO
GET BACK TO PARADISE IF THAT'S-
WHAT THEY WERE WORKING. SO I'M
WORRIED THAT THE WORLD IS GOING
TO WATCHES AND OTHER PEOPLE ARE
ARE ARE. WATCHING THIS
LEGISLATION AND SAYING OH MY
GOD HERE'S ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
TO DO A SEQUEL EXEMPTION.
BECAUSE OF A FIRE FOR AREAS IN
CITIES. THAT WERE NOT AFFECTED
THE WE'RE NOT AFFECTED AND
FINALLY THIS SIX YEAR ERIOD
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS BILL AS
I READ IT. THAT DOESN'T ALLOW
FOR THE ANNEXATION OF LAND IN
THE SIX CITIES FURTHER SIX OF
THE CITY'S COULD ACTUALLY
CHANGE THE INCORPORATION OF
SOME LAND THAT'S NOT IN PRIME
FARMLAND AND ALLOW FOR UNITS.
FOR THE ACRE TO BE. DANCE WITH
THAT I WILL BE VOTING NO AN
URGENT NO PHONE. SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE SEMI
MEMBER AND A GOOD FRIEND
SENATOR FROM TO HEMA AND MYSELF
TO BRING THIS BILL FORWARD WE
HAD A VIGOROUS DISCUSSION I
WANNA SHARE FIRST A MINUTE
ABOUT WE TALK ABOUT CAMPFIRE
AND IT'S IN MOST PEOPLE THINK
OF PARADISE BUT THERE'S A
COMMUNITY ABOVE PARADISE WHICH
IS WE GET A WHICH I FORMALLY
REPRESENTED IN THE ASSEMBLY I
DON'T HAVE ANY OF YOU COUNTY MY
SENATE SEAT BUT- I HAD NINETEEN
THOUSAND CONSTITUENTS IN. BUTTE
COUNTY AND ELEVEN THOUSAND THEM
WERE DISPLACED BY THE CAMPFIRE.
WE'RE SIMPLY TRYING TO. GET
THEIR LIVES BACK TOGETHER AND
ALLOW THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD TO BUILD THE NOW THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM FREMONT BROUGHT UP
SOME GREAT POINTS ABOUT THE
DISTANCES. HE'S TALKING ABOUT
BUT YOU HAVE TO IF YOU VISITED
THE AREA AND YOU SEE WHERE THE
COMMUNITIES ARE. AND HOW THEY
ARE MORE SPREAD OUT IN THE
NORTH PART OF THE STATE. YOU
HAVE TO MOVE OUT OF THE YOUR
SPEAR IN THAT ONE AREA WHERE
THE FIRE WAS AND WE HAD THIS
BILL UP IN EQ IN THE GOOD
SENATOR. AND I DEBATED ABOUT
THE BILL THIS BILL DOES NOT
ALLOW A CITY OR COUNTY TO. GO
OUTSIDE THEIR GENERAL PLANS AND
IF YOU'VE BEEN IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
A GENERAL PLAN DOES IT'S THE
PLAN IT IS BEEN LAID OUT.
THROUGH THE LAW TO BUILD OUT
YOUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES THIS
BILL WILL SIMPLY ALLOW THEM TO
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS WITH IN
THE GENERAL PLANS OF THOSE
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT ARE
DESIGNATED. IN THIS BILL. THIS
IS A GOOD BILL IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO SHOW THE
PEOPLE WHEN YOU'VE HAD A
NATURAL DISASTER YOUR
COMMUNITY. THE LARGEST IN THE
NATION AMONG THE MOST
DEVASTATING WILDFIRE IN THE
COUNTRY'S HISTORY. HAPPENED
RIGHT IN OUR BACKYARD. I THINK
IT IS WOULD BE DISINGENUOUS FOR
THIS LEGISLATURE NOT TO ALLOW
US TO BUILD HOMES FOR THOSE
FOLKS IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AROUND AND REBUILD THE NOR
STATE SO I STRONGLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL WE HAD
BIGGEST DEBATE AND THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
HELPING PEOPLE GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN SENATOR NIELSEN
YOU MAY CONCLUDE THAT A
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES OF THE
SENATE I BEGIN MY CLOTHES WITH
WOW. WOW. DO YOU WONDER WHY
PEOPLE IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE. HAVE CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF WHAT GOES ON DOWN HERE.
RURAL AREAS ARE NOT JUST IN THE
NORTH. IN THE SOUTH AND THE
CENTRAL. WE'RE GONNA HAVE SUCH
DISREGARD FOR THEM. BUT SHE
WILL OFFER A STADIUM WHOLE
HEAVEN'S SAKES YES OLD GAS
THAT'S ALL ABOUT MONEY. NOT
PEOPLE MONEY ENTERTAINMENT. NOW
I WILL FOR THESE BILLS AND IT
JUST A LITTLE EARLIER TODAY.
BUT NOW WE HAVE A DISASTER OF
UNPRECEDENTED MAGNITUDE. TO OUR
COMMITTEE WHICH MY. CALLING
FROM BEAVER SPOKE TO WE
ACTUALLY HAD ORGANIZATION COME
UP. AND SAY WE DON'T WANT TO
REBUILD UP THERE. THEIR GOAL IS
AN ORGANIZATION IS TO DE
POPULATE RURAL CALIFORNIA.
DEPOPULATED NO MORE GROWTH. NOW
WE'RE GONNA CARRY THAT OVER
INTO THE GAME. AKON CAL THE
PARADOX. YEAH AND RURAL AREAS
SOME POPULATED AREAS ARE FIFTY
MILES AWAY. AND YEAH. IN OUR
RURAL COUNTIES PEOPLE MOVED.
NOT ONLY FIFTY MILES AWAY BUT
IN ALL ALL BUT I THINK FIVE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA ACCEPTED.
RESIDENTS FROM BUTTE COUNTY.
WHO WERE DISPLACED BUT THIS
CATASTROPHIC FIRE. WE'VE ALWAYS
SHOWN SENSITIVITY. HERE TO OUR
COLLEAGUES WHEN THEY FACED THE
DISASTER. A FEW WEEKS AGO I
SPOKE ABOUT THE BERKELEY FIRE.
MY DEAR FRIEND SENATOR NICK
PETROUS DO LOST NOT ONLY IS
HOME THE TREASURED LIBRARY. WE
DIDN'T HESITATE AND SAY WELL NO
WE NEED TO TAKE OUR TIME AND
LET'S NOT BE IN A HURRY WE'RE
GOING TO REBUILD THE BAY AREA
WHEN THE BRIDGES COLLAPSED AND-
IN THE EARTHQUAKE. WE GOT ABOUT
THE BUSINESS AT HAND. THE
FIXINGS AS QUICKLY AS WE COULD.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERN HERE
I THINK IS A THAT IS A- DEREK
ARGUMENT. AND IT'S ALMOST
DISGUSTING. TO HEAR SUCH AN
ARGUMENT WHEN WE HAVE FACED
SUCH A CRISIS. BUT I SAID IN
THAT COMMITTEE TO THOSE.
WITNESSES WHO WERE FOR US. I
WISH SOME OF THE PEOPLE FROM
BUTTE COUNTY. WE'RE HERE WITH
ME TODAY. THE LOOK YOU IN THE
EYE. AND HERE YOU'RE CONSCIOUS
DISREGARD. FOR THEIR LIVES I
ASK AN IDOL. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS BATES BY
BELL BY PORCHES HI BRADFORD. BY
CAMBIADO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD I DORADO. GALGIANI. GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ. GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO I TITLE BY
JACKSON. JONES HI LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. MONNING
MORE LUCK. I AM A REAL BY
NELSON I PAN. I PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN. STONE HI NUMBER I WOULD
COUNTY NO WIENER AYE WILK BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN. ATKINS. THERE ALSO HI
GALGIANI I. GONZALEZ GROWTH
JACKSON MITCHELL MONNING STERN.
WHEN THEY. ICE THIRTY ONE KNOWS
ONE THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE FIFTY SENATOR
DOLLY. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN OH
ONE BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON AGRICULTURE IN EQUITY CATTLE
AND MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE CENTER DOLLY THE
FLOOR HEATERS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I THIS IS THIS IS A
COMMITTEE BILL AB EIGHTEEN OH
ONE ON AGRICULTURAL BILL
RELATING TO CATTLE THE BILL
DOES THE FOLLOWING ELIMINATES
REQUIREMENT THAT CERTAIN
CALUMNY PROVEN VACCINATION FROM
BURKE YOU LOS IS AT THE CHANGE
OF OWNERSHIP WITH IN
CALIFORNIA. NUMBER TWO UPDATES
THE CURRENT MAN FEE STRUCTURE
AND AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT NAG TO INCREASE THE
LIVESTOCK INSPECTION BRAND FEE
BY 20% WITH APPROVAL OF THE
LIVESTOCK IDENTIFICATION
ADVISORY BOARD NUMBER THREE
CHANGES THE RECENT MOBILE
SLAUGHTER LAW TO APPLY TO
CATTLE ONLY A NUMBER FOR ADDS
EXEMPTIONS TO THE FEE
COLLECTION OF THE RECENT CATTLE
KHALKHAL LAW TO CONFORM. WITH
THE NATIONAL BE COUNCIL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARTS LETTER I
ATKINS BATES. HI BILL I
PURCHASED BY BRADFORD.
COPYRIGHT. BRADFORD AYE
COPYRIGHTS CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD ARE THERE ALSO I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW
HERTZBERG. HILL AYE HUESO I
TITLE I JACKSON AYE JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONNING. I'M MORE LOCK I AM
A REAL AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG CASKEY. WIENER AYE
WILK HI SENATOR DOLLY MOVES A
CALL. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM NMBER THREE FIFTY FIVE
SENATOR WIENER. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE. THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
AN ACTOR LINDA BUSINESS CENTER
WIENER I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT SOME AGO FOURTEEN
NINETY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN. BY A
BEFORE TO NINETY SEVEN WILL
INCLUDE A PROPERTY LISTED ON
OUR ONLINE HOSTING PLATFORM IN
THE DEFINITION OF A HOUSING
ACCOMMODATION AB FOURTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WERE CAUGHT UP BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING IS CURRENT
PRACTICE. OF INVESTIGATING
COMPLAINTS OF DISCRIMINATION
AND PROVIDING HELP FOR THE
VICTIMS BY THE BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT HOSTS QUOTE UNQUOTE CANNOT
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS OF
RACE COLOR RELIGION SEX GENDER
GENDER IDENTITY GENDER
EXPRESSION HI SEXUAL
ORIENTATION MARITAL STATUS
NATIONAL ORIGIN ANCESTRY.
FAMILIAL STATUS SOURCE OF
INCOME DISABILITY OR GENETIC
INFORMATION REPORTS OF
DISCRIMINATION ON AIRBNB AND
THE RPO PROPERTIES ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE MADE HEADLINES ALL
THESE COMPLAINTS HAVE BECOME
MORE COMMON OF THE REGULATED
ENTITY IS A LEGAL AREA THIS
LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE.
CLARIFICATION AND OUR CLASS FOR
ALL. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. I BRADFORD. I
KELLY AT ALL I CHIANG I DALY
AYE DODD ARE THERE ALSO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROVE HERTZBERG
HILL. AYE HUESO I TADO I
JACKSON. HI JONES BY LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI MONNING
I'M. MORE LUCK I AM AREAL AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN. I PORTANTINO I
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER BY
STERN. BY STONE. BY AMBERG OUR
CASKEY WIENER AYE WILK. HI HI.
SENATOR WIENER MOVES THE CALL
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
FIFTY SIX SENATOR GLACIER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS ARE IN AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALING ARTS
CENTER GLAZER THANK YOU MATT
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS THIS MICROPHONE WORKING
THERE YOU GO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FIFTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS ARIANNA
WOULD ALLOW LICENSE OPTOMETRIST
TO BRING VISION SERVICES IN
TESTING THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CONFINED TO THEIR HOMES. THE
CHANGE THIS BILL WOULD IMPROVE
ACCESS FOR CRITICALLY
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS SUCH AS
SENIORS AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
MENTAL OR PHYSICAL DISABILITIES
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED UNDER. SERVED AREAS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
RECEIVE KNOWN NO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. THING
MAN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES I
BILL I PURCHASED AYE BRADFORD
AYE CAMBIADO I CHIANG AYE DALY
AYE DODD BY THE RISE OF AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG
HILL. I HUESO I IDOLATOR I
JACKSON. I JONES. HI LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK I'M A
REAL. I NIELSEN I PAN I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE HAMBURG. IOWA CASKEY.
WIENER AYE WILK HI SENATOR
GLAZER MOVES A CALL MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE FIFTY
SEVEN SENATOR WIENER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AN ACT
REALLY IN THE HEALING ARTS.
SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TO IMPRISON AB TWO
FORTY ONE ON BEHALF OF SOMEONE
RECALL MARGARET THE OF HI THIS
BILL WILL REDUCE DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH CARE. BY MANDATING THAT
CONTINUED EDUCATION COURSES
REQUIRED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA THE POSITION
SYSTEM BOARD AND THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING INCLUDE
CURRICULA THESE ARE ABOUT
IMPLICIT BIAS. THE CURRICULUM
WILL NEED TO INCLUDE EXAMPLES
OF HOW IMPLICIT BIAS AFFECTS
PERCEPTIONS AND TREATMENT. AND
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE UNINTENDED
BIASES AND DECISION MAKING THAT
MAY CONTRIBUTE TO HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES. IMPLICIT BIAS
COMPRENDE THE LIVES OF PATIENTS
BY CONTRIBUTING. THE UNEQUAL
TREATMENT OF PEOPLE BASED ON A
NUMBER OF CLASSIFIED DOCTORS
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
CONSTANTLY MAKE RAPID DECISIONS
UNDER STRESSFUL CONDITIONS.
THAT MAY ALTER A PATIENT'S
LIFE. IF WE SUB CONSCIOUSLY
BELIEVE IT'S OUR LIVES ARE LESS
VALUABLE THAN OTHERS THEN WE
MAY BE LESS LIKELY TO TRY TO
SAVE THOSE LIVES. STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT BLACK WOMEN ARE
THREE TO FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO DIE. FROM PREGNANCY OR
CHILDBIRTH RELATED CAUSES AND
WHITE. WOMEN ARE MORE LIKELY TO
SURVIVE A HEART ATTACK WHEN
TREATED BY A FEMALE PHYSICIAN.
80% OF PEOPLE WHO IDENTIFY AS
LGBTQ AVOID DOCTORS OFFICES FOR
FEAR OF DISCRIMINATION AND
PROVIDER BY US. AND THE
TIANANMEN IN CALIFORNIA OR 21%
LESS LIKELY TO RECEIVE THE BEST
TREATMENT FOR HIGH RISK
PROSTATE CANCER BEN ARE WHITE
MEN. CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF IMPROVING
TREATMENT OUTCOMES FOR PATIENTS
WHO BEEN UNDERSERVED. PASSED
LEGISLATION INTEGRATING
CULTURAL COMPETENCY CURRICULUM
AND TO CONTINUE MEDICAL
EDUCATION HAS WORKED BUT WE
NEED TO EXPAND THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM RIVAL.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NNE ST MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARE SO THAT A- ATKINS
BATES. BELL I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD I CAN BE ERA I CHIANG
I DALY. DOT BY THE RISE OF. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ
I GROW. HERTZBERG HILL AYE
HUESO. HI TITLE I JACKSON AYE
JONES. LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE BY
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LOCK. I AM A REAL. NIELSEN I
PAN I PORTANTINO HI ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NUMBER BY KELSEY. WIENER
BY WILK. HI. SENATOR WIENER
MOVES A CALL. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE FIFTY NINE SENATOR
JACKSON MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AN ACT
RELATING TO AGING. FOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A MEASURE
THAT WOULD HELP TO PROVIDE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION FOR
SENIORS AND THE DISABLED TO
THEIR HEALTH CARE APPOINTMENTS.
IT WOULD ESTABLISH A GRANT
PROGRAM WITHIN THE CLEAN
MOBILITY OPTIONS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD FOR THE
PURCHASE OR LEASE OF ZERO
EMISSION OR NEW YEAR'S ORAL
MISSION OF VEHICLES. TO PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION TO AND FROM NON
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE
APPOINTMENTS FOR OLDER
INDIVIDUALS IN THOSE LIVING
WITH A DISABILITY WE KNOW THE
CHALLENGES THESE PEOPLE FACE
AND WITH THE REMOVAL. OF OR I
SHOULD SAY BY REMOVING THE
OPPOSITION BY THE SHEER CLUB
FOR ADDING A NEW AMENDMENT
PRIORITIZING ZERO EMISSION
SHUTTLE BUSES THE MEASURE NOW
HAS NO OPPOSITION SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK. YOUR AYE VOTE.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. HI BILL I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD I CAN BE I CHIANG I
DALY. DODD HI RUSSEL. I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
BY GROWTH. I HERTZBERG HILL AYE
HUESO. I TITLE I JACKSON AYE
JONES. I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. I MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK I'M REAL BY NELSON. I PAN
HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN. BY STONE.
I AM BURKE I WOULD COUNTY.
INNER BY WILK HI CENTER JACKSON
MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD TO THREE NINETY
SIX. SENATOR MONNING MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS
THEY'RE MONNING THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THE 10% BID
PREFERENCE IS A SCORING CREDIT
ON A STATE BID FOR A TRANSIT
OPERATOR WHO VOLUNTARILY AGREES
TO RETAIN QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES
FROMTHE PREVIOUS CONTRACTOR
FOR A MINIMUM OF NINETY DAYS
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY FIVE
EXTENDS THE EMPLOYEE RETENTION
10% BID PREFERENCE TO ALL
PUBLIC TRANSIT CONTRACTS
AWARDED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WILL PREVENT
UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY TRANSIT
WORKER LAYOFFS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. BY ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES NO BELL. BY BURGESS NO
BRADFORD. I CARRY ERA I CHIANG.
NO DALY NO DOT. HI THERE ALSO.
GALGIANI. HI THERE ALSO HI
GLAZER GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO. I
TOTAL. JACKSON HI JONES. NO
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN. NO PAN BY
PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER BY STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER. OUR CASKEY BY WINNER BY
WILK NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS GLAZER BY.
MURTADA HI STONE NO. ICE TWENTY
EIGHT NOS ELEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE GETTING VERY
CLOSE TO THE END OF OUR
SCHEDULE FOR TODAY SO GOOD JOB
WITH ONLY GOT A COUPLE MORE TO
TAKE UP AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK UP. TO THOSE FOR THOSE
BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR FIFTY
THREE. SENATOR BELL. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AN ACTOR
LINDA TRANSPORTATION. SENATOR
BELL THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THIS
BILL MATTER MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS EXTENSIVE SUNSET FOR A
STUDY BEING DONE ON TRUCK WITH
TUNING TECHNOLOGIES SO NEEDS TO.
BE APPROVED SAWYER CHEN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE I. I
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES
. MEMBERS IF YOU'LL ALLOW
ME TO TAKE A- MINUTE TO CONFER
.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO LEFT THE
CALLS ON THE ITEMS THAT HAVE
BEEN PLACED ON CALL. WE WILL
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN SB THREE OH
THREE. WHICH IS THE UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FROM THIS MORNING.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ATKINS. HI BY CHANGE CHECK OUR.
AYE AYES FORTY NO ZERO THEM THE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE TWENTY AB THIRTEEN
OH NINE. FROM THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. YOUR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. LEYVA HI.
ZERO THE MEASURE BROWN EYES
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM NUMBER THREE
TWENTY ONE AB SIX TWENTY FOUR.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
WELL I LEYVA HI. ICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS ELEVEN MEASURE
PASSES. FILE NUMBER THREE
TWENTY THREE AB ONE IS SEVENTY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ARCHULETA ATKINS I
BRADFORD. DODD GLAZER. HILL
ROTH RUBIO. NUMBER. I IS
NINETEEN KNOWS THIRTEEN MEASURE
FAILS. SENATOR DORADO MOVES
RECONSIDERATION WITHOUT
OBJECTION. READ RECONSIDERATION
IS GRANTED. AYE AYES FORTY NO
ZERO. MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE FIFTY. AB EIGHTEEN OH ONE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ATKINS ATKINS. HI GROVE HI
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG. I Y.
CASKEY. HI. THEIR EYES FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES ITEM
THREE FIFTY FIVE AB FOURTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. PLEASE READ
ATKINS PLEASE HI GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG. BY Y. CASKEY. BY.
EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES ITEM NUMBER THREE FIFTY
SIX AB FOUR FIFTY EIGHT. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE
ATKINS. HI HERTZBERG. BY WHY
COUNTY HI. VICE FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. FOR CALLING
ITEM NUMBER THREE FIFTY SEVEN
AB TWO FORTY ONE. PLEASE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. I BATES HI FOR JUST.
DALY GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI JONES.
RL STONE NUMBER. BY LIKE OWSKI
BY. I THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES ITEM NUMBER
THREE FIFTY NINE AB NINE
SEVENTY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ATKINS HI YES. HI DOLLY.
HERTZBERG BY LIKE OWSKI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS DALLY
DALY AYE. I KELSEY. ICE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
OKAY. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE FILE IN TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER TWO NINETY FOUR.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FORTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE
AN ACT RELATING TO CIVIL
ACTIONS. AWESOME THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AB SEVEN FORTY
NINE WILL PROHIBIT SO CALLED.
NO HIGHER PROVISIONS RICK NO
REHIRE SORRY NO RE HIGHER
PROVISIONS THAT RESTRICT AN
EMPLOYEE'S ABILITY TO SEEK
FUTURE EMPLOYMENT WITH AN
EMPLOYER. THIS PROHIBITION
WOULD ONLY APPLY WHERE AN
EMPLOYEE HAS FILED A COMPLAINT
ALLEGING HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION OR OTHER
UNLAWFUL CONDUCT ON THE PART OF
THE EMPLOYER. THE USE OF NO RE
HIGHER PROVISION TO OFTEN
CONSTITUTES. RETALIATION
AGAINST AN EMPLOYEE WHO HAS
FILED A COMPLAINT AGAINST AN
EMPLOYER. AB SEVEN FORTY NINE
WILL ONLY APPLY TO A SETTLEMENT
WITH AN AGGRIEVED EMPLOYEE THAT
IS AN EMPLOYEE WHO HAS FILED A
COMPLAINT OR BROUGHT AN ACTION
AGAINST THE EMPLOYERS WRONG
DOING. IT WILL NOT APPLY TO AN
EMPLOYEE WHO IS THE PERPETRATOR
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR SEXUAL
ASSAULT. NOTHING IN THIS BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT ON EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEE FROM THE GO SHADING TO
TERMINATE A CURRENT EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIP AND NOTHING IN
THIS BILL WOULD INTERFERE WITH
THE EMPLOYER'S ABILITY TO
TERMINATE OR REFUSE TO RE HIRE.
AN EMPLOYEE FOR LEGITIMATE
REASONS I THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
ATKINS AYE BATES NOBEL I
PURCHASED NO BRADFORD.
CABALLERO NO CHIANG. NO DALY NO
DOT. THERE ARE SO. HI GALGIANI
NO LASER. GONZALEZ BY GROVE NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
OUR TOTAL. JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
BY MONEY. HI MORE LOCK NO
MERRELL NO NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO BY. RUBIO. I SKINNER
AYE STERN. BY STONE NO I'M
BURKE. HI MY COUNTY I WINNER BY
WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA BRADFORD.
DOT GLAZER. WITH SO TITLE. ROTH.
DRUGS MOVES A CALL. WE HAVE A
SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT FROM
SENATOR MCGUIRE. VIRTUAL AND.
MEMBERS WE APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING
TODAY. WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
LOOK TOWARDS TOMORROW TOMORROW
THE CITY IS GOING TO BE WORKING
INTO THE EVENING. WE'VE
IDENTIFIED APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
FOUR TO THIRTY SIX BILLS THAT
HAVE SENATE FLOOR MANAGERS THAT
WERE NOT TAKEN UP TODAY. WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO ASK IS THAT EACH
YEAR OFFICES AND WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR DESK UNIT EACH
OF THE OFFICES IF YOU DON'T
MIND CHECK IN WITH THE DESK
UNIT IN THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
OFFICE. TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
THOSE BILLS TOMORROW EVENING.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA ASK. WE
HAVE TWENTY FOUR TO THIRTY SIX
ADDITIONAL BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED. WITH SENATORS AS
FLOOR MANAGERS. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE COORDINATE
WITH THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
OFFICE AND THE DESK UNIT TO BE
ABLE TO GET THOSE BILLS MOVED
TOMORROW WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR COOPERATION IN. TRULY
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR WORK.
YOUR AND EVEN THEN LIKE TODAY
YET. THE. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
ANNOUNCEMENTS. OKAY PRIVILEGE
OF THE FLOOR SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY
I WANT TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE OUR
SOMEONE THAT SITS HERE EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND IT DAY IN AND
DAY OUT TO HELP US OUT SO
PLEASE HELP ME CONGRATULATE
CLIENT WENT THIS WHO'S BACK
FROM MATERNITY LEAVE WHO HAD
HER BABY BOY GIOVANNI FUENTES.
BACKGROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR THAN
THE AMOUNT. THANK YOU
. MEMBERS
IF YOU COULD GIVE US A MOMENT
.
MEMBERS PLEASE STAY ON THE
FLOOR WE HAVE NOT FINISHED ALL
OF OUR BUSINESS FOR THE DAY
.
OKAY MEMBERS. JUST TO PROVE
THAT NO. GOOD DEED GOES
UNPUNISHED WE HAVE SOME MORE
THAT JUST GOT ADDED TO THE FILE
THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP TODAY
SO WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
FILE NUMBER THREE FIFTY THREE.
SENATOR STONE. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FIFTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA ENACT WILLING TO
TRAVEL GAME IN THE CLING
THERE'S THROUGHOUT THE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. UNDER STONE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
AMANDA PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
I'M VERY PROUD TO PRESENT A. B.
SEVEN FIFTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMAN EDUARDO GARCIA.
THIS BILL IS A VEHICLE OUT FOR
THE RATIFICATIONOF THE NEW
TRIBAL GAMING CONTACT BETWEEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CABAZON BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY THAT HAVE
BEEN GREAT FRIENDS AND GREAT
STEWARDS OF. OF LAND AND
PROSPERITY IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
THE NEW CAMPUS ON COMPACT WAS
EXECUTED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOME ON
AUGUST TWENTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI.
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BILL I BRIDGES I BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO HI I CHIANG. I DALY
AYE DODD AYE THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH I HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO HI TITLE HI JACKSON I
JONES I LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LOCK I'M A REAL I NIELSEN AYE
PAN. PORTANTINO HI ROB.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. HI RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
I AMBERG OUR COUNTY. HI WE
WINNER HI WILK BY. SENATOR
STONE MOVES A CALL. A REMINDER
TO MEMBERS TO PLEASE STAY ON
THE FLOOR AND WE WANT TO GET
THROUGH THESE AND MKE SURE WE
CATCH A VOTE. ITEM NUMBER THREE
FORTY FIVE. SENATOR ALAN.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AN ACT
RELATING TO SOLID WASTE.
SENATOR ALLEN MEMBERS I
RESERVOIRS IN AB TWENTY SEVEN
WHICH WILL HELP OUR STATE
REACHES AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS
BY HAVING RESTAURANTS OTHER
FOOD SERVICE FACILITIES PROVIDE
BINS FOR RECYCLABLES AND
COMPOSTABLE WASTES. NOW I KNOW
THAT THEY TOOK SOME AMENDMENTS
THAT CHANGE THE CONCERT WITH
ADDRESS CONCERNS AT THE
RESTAURANTS FOLKS HAD WITH
REGARD TO THIS BILL. AND AS A
RESULT THOSE AMENDMENTS HAVE
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION. THIS IS
A WIN WIN IT WILL HELP TO
REDUCE. RGH CHEESE AND ALSO
HELP US BEGIN TO PROBABLY SORT
THEIR FOOD WASTE BUT I'D I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE AGAIN. ASSN THE
MEMBERS WERE TAKEN OF RELATING
TO FLEXIBILITY AS TO THE
PLACEMENT OF THE BANDS AND NOT
DROP ANY OPPOSITION OTHER
RESTAURANTS ASSOCIATIONS AND
NOW HAS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION. I
TO GET BILL AND I RESPECT
FASHION ABOUT. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BILL I PURCHASED NO BRADFORD
I CAN BE AT ALL I CHIANG HI
DOLLY. DOT. HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO AYE HURTADO.
JACKSON HI JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL NO NIELSEN NO PAN.
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK HI. MOORLACH I DON'T
KNOW. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS DALLY NO GROWTH NO
TITLE JONES NO. PAN. SENATOR
ALLEN MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA LEFT THE CALL ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO NINETY FOUR.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
OUR PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL.
ARCHULETA BRADFORD. DODD GLAZER
WITH SO. OUR TOTAL. ROTH
BRADFORD HI. I TWENTY ONE KNOWS
THIRTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SIXTY EIGHT. SENATOR
HILL MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON
AND ACTUALLY INTO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. CENTER
HELD FOR YEARS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB TEN SEVENTY TWO
PROVIDES CLARITY TO SMALL
UTILITIES OF FEWER THAN TEN
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS PRIMARILY
WATER AND TELEPHONE PROVIDERS
ABOUT THE STANDARDS UNDER WHICH
THE P. YOU SEE MUCH COMPLETE AN
AUDIT OR REVIEW OF THEIR
UTILITIES SMALL UTILITIES OFTEN
HAVE VERY FEW EMPLOYEES AND
LIMITED REVENUE. AND IN MANY
CASES A REVIEW WOULD BE A MORE
APPROPRIATE ACCOUNTING STANDARD
THAT A FULL AUDIT THIS BILL
ALSO HELPS AVOID DUPLICATION
DUPLICATION OF UNNECESSARY WORK
BY CLARIFYING THAT AN AUDIT OR
REVIEW DONE IN CONCURRENCE WITH
THE COMPLETION OF A GENERAL
RATE CASE. IS SATISFACTORY
FINALLY AB TEN SEVENTY TWO
ENSURES TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING THE P. YOU SEE TO
PUBLICLY POST THEIR AUDITING
PROCESS AND STANDARDS THIS BILL
IS NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT THE
CPUC COMPLIES WITH THE AUDITING
STANDARDS OUTLINED IN STATUTE.
IN A TIMELY AND TRANSPARENT
MANNER THIS MEASURE HAS KNOWN
NO KNOWN OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE
COLLEAGUES. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SINGMAN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BILL. HI BURGESS. HI
BRADFORD HI KELLY HERO HI I
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE
THERE ALSO. GALGIANI I GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ I GROW I HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO HI TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. BY
MONNING AYE MOORLAH AYE
MORRELL AYE NIELSEN. I PAN.
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
HI I'M BURKE. OUR COUNTY.
WIENER AYE WILK HI SENATOR HILL
MOVES A CALL. CENTERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
THIRTY SIX. SENATOR CHIANG.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
AN ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION. UNDER CHIANG THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS AB THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE WOULD REQUIRE THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION TO INCLUDE THE
HISTORY AND CULTURAL STUDY OF
LOTION AMERICANS DURING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CURRICULUM
RELATIVE TO THE VIETNAMESE WAR
REFUGEE EXPERIENCE IN AMERICA.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
ARE CLARIFYING IN NATURE THIS
BILL CORRECTION OVERSIGHT LAST
YEAR'S SB EIGHT NINE FIVE WHICH
REQUIRES THAT I CAN SEE TO
DEVELOP MODEL CURRICULUM
RELATIVE TO VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
REFUGEE EXPERIENCE. THE HISTORY
OF LAOTIAN REFUGEES IN THE
COUNT THE COUNTRY OF LAOS WHICH
IS INSEPARABLE FROM THE HISTORY
THE VIETNAM WAR WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN SB EIGHT NINE FIVE.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY THREE IS
CLEAN UP LANGUAGE TO CORRECT
THIS UNINTENDED AND EXCLUSION
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES IN POLICY
COMMITTEE OR ON THE FLOOR. I
RESPECTFULLY ROUTE REQUEST I
VOTE. OR ANY MEASURE TO BET ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE MISTER
SET SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BY BILL. BY
BURGESS HI BRADFORD AYE
CAMBIADO I CHIANG KAI DELI I
DODD. HI THERE ALSO. I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
I HERTZBERG. HILL WITH SO. HIGH
TITLE. I JACKSON HI. JONES HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL.
HI MONNING HI MORE LUCK. MORALE.
I NIELSEN. AYE PAN. PORTANTINO
I ROTH. I RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG I
WOULD COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HERTZBERG HI MORE LOCK. PAN.
SENATOR CHAIN MOVE THE CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
CONCURRENCE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
FIVE. SENATOR STONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR STONE AN ACT RELATING
TO VESSELS CENTER STONE THANK
ABOUT A PRESIDENT'S SB THREE
NINETY THREE IS BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY ON CONCURRENCE
REMEMBER THAT SB THREE NINETY
THREE STATES THAT IF A VESSEL
IS USED IN THE COMMISSION OF A
VOTING UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF
OFTEN THE UNLAWFUL KILLING OF A
PERSON THAT VESSEL WILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME SEIZURE AN
IMPOUND ROLES AS A- VEHICLE AND
A DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
CRIME. THE MM IS HER RELATING
TO LIMITING THE LIABILITY
MEMORY OWNERS GOD NO NO NO IFS
IN THE IN THE SENATE THE SO I
URGE YOUR CONCURRENT VOTE ON SB
THREE NINETY THREE WITH THE US
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY THE ROLE PLEASE.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BILL. I A
PURCHASE I BRADFORD I CAN BE AT
ALL I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD.
HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI. I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROW. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
TITLE. I JACKSON I JONES. BY
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL BY NELSON. HI PAN
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH. I RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
I AMBERG OUR COUNTY. I WIENER
AYE WILK HI BY. CENTER STONE
MOVES THE CALL
. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT HAS A MOTION OR A
RESOLUTION. SENATOR ROBB DID
YOU HAVE A MOTION RESOLUTION
THAT YOU INTENDED TO PRESENT
TODAY. THE. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RETURN SENATE BILL
FIVE EIGHTY SIX TO THE ASSEMBLY
FOR FURTHER ACTION. IT'S SO
ORDERED. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WHO HAS A MOTION RESOLUTION
.
MEMBER WERE MEMBERS WERE
WAITING TO TAKE UP THE BILLS
THAT ARE ON CALL SO IF YOU GIVE
US JUST A MINUTE. GET FULL SOME
BE ABLE TO FINISH UP
. MEMBERS
WERE IN IT TAKE UP THE FILE THE
BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL. LIKE TO
START WITH FILE NUMBER THREE
FIFTY THREE AB SEVEN FIFTY
THREE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN. PAN AYE.
THEY'RE ON THEIR EYES FORTY NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY EASE FIVE
FORTY NO ZERO. ON THE BILL THE
MEASURE PASSES. PICKING UP FILE
NUMBER THREE FORTY FIVE AB
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS TITLE. PAN.
PAN AYE. THE MEASURE PASSED ICE
THIRTY KNOWS NINE MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM NUMBER TWO SIXTY
EIGHT AB TEN SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS DORADO.
HI PAN. BY KELSEY. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. PAN HI BY
KELSEY. AND AS THEIR EYES
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM NUMBER THREE
THIRTY SIX AB THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MORE LUCK I. HI. SIZE
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
FIVE SB THREE NINETY THREE ON
BACK ON COULD ON AN UNFINISHED
BUSINESS ON CONCURRENCE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS PAN HI.
SIZE FORTY NO ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED WITH
. MEMBERS THAT
CONCLUDES THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. IF. IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR
ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE
CERTAINLY HOPE TO GET A LOT
MORE BILLS DONE I'M GONNA
REPEAT WHAT. MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
SAID EARLIER IF YOU CAN TALK TO
YOUR ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES FOR
BILLS THAT YOU ARE MANAGING THE
QUICKER WE GET SOME OF THOSE
BILLS OFF THE FLOOR. THE LAST
LATE WE WILL BE HERE EACH NIGHT
THIS WEEK IF THAT'S THE
INCENTIVE EYES WERE MAKE SURE
YOU UNDERSTANDING CONNECT THE
DOTS ON THAT. SO THANK YOU FOR
THE HARD WORK THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO GET DONE TODAY THANK YOU TO
THE FLOOR TEAM WEEK AT FORTY
SIX ASSEMBLY BILLS PASSED NINE
SENATE BILLS CONCURRED IN. AND
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND I ALSO WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SOMEONE'S BIRTHDAY
BUT I'M LOOKING TO SEE WHERE HE
MIGHT HAVE GONE. ARE THE AREAS
I SEE THAT FACE. I WANNA IT
YESTERDAY LABOR DAY HAPPEN TO
BE ARE GOOD MY GOOD ARE GOOD
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN DIEGO'S
BIRTHDAY. AND NOW. WHERE DO WE
DON'T WE DON'T DO THAT ON THE
FLOOR WE'RE GOING TO WISH HIM A
VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY AND WERE
OUT AT FOUR O'CLOCK WHICH MEANS
IT'S EARLY ENOUGH THAT IF WE
WANT TO SPEND TIME A KNOWLEDGE
IN HIM A DIFFERENT WAY WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT.
ALTHOUGH I WOULD SAY TO THE
PRESIDENT AS WE ARE ADJOURNED
THAT EVEN THOUGH YOU MIGHT WANT
TO DO THAT WITH MY COLLEAGUE
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO I
STILL WE'LL SEE YOU ALL HERE
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER FOURTH AT
TEN AM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU THE SENATE
WILL BE ADJOURNED AND WE WILL
RECONVENE TOMORROW WEDNESDAY AT
TEN AM. THANK YOU